e
find your G oh we gave it away don't you
right are you're not a floor whip what
is your
your floor
leader I don't know I don't know what
I'm
doing surpr me what's the title what's
you
okay what's that don't my I I gave my
gavl
away I gave my gavl away did at the end
of the
session no who was who did I give it to
I gave it to um to Jane Jane I did I
gave it to Jane so but I will get a new
one they do issue me a new one soon but
I guess I should have brought another
one of my old ones in but at any rate uh
good morning everyone um I am John Hunt
I live in live in ringe New Hampshire um
and over the year over the year you'll
all get to hear one of my wonderful
stories that I have since this is my
38th year here I've been here um having
said that um I do want to uh begin with
have introductions because we do have
several new members and then the new
members can get to meet some of the old
members I would say this year um is the
the the least amount of turnover that
Commerce had and historically we've
always had a lot uh lot of turnover but
uh this this time around uh it seems
like everybody on the Republican
Democrats a lot return
and came back which is good so what did
you say about Republicans but
Republicans and Democrats returned
Democrats okay yeah no I said it's been
been a
great coming back and as you all notice
that uh my minority leader and I have
gotten to know each other very well over
the
years and uh things can be very casual
here so uh I know that other committees
you'll find that we're not as as casual
as we are so so
uh don't don't take what we happen to do
here and then go think you can do it in
another committee because I've heard
horror stories about that so um we'll
start go around we'll
uh you're going to be first because I
can't pronounce your name until I've
me yeah good you have to push the the
button on the right with the guy
speaking yep perfect okay man Mano
chasia from uh hborg County District 11
okay okay you know tell us a little
something exciting about your life
and well uh I am
a IT professional and I am an
entrepreneur too and uh I have lived in
Nashville for 22 plus years okay yeah
all right next up
Pres hello I'm Adam pieza pza I'm a
master student at new College just down
the road and I'm also a realtor so if
any of you need to sell your house just
just come to
appreciated well that's good because we
well we used to have more real estate
but we think thankfully got rid of
condos and and manufactured housing
parks and those kind of issues which no
one wants to we're happy to share with a
separate committee which representative
Cole is now Vice chair of M thank you
Brian Cole Manchester New Hampshire
Hillsboro 26 I actually retired last
year so uncle could to be up here
full-time got my bachelor's degree in
economics and Finance and Accounting
from Southern New
Hampshire
great good morning everyone my name is
Susan pelli I represent uh Rockingham
District 19 Hampton Falls and Kensington
on the beautiful Sea Coast and I
actually was a colleague with uh Mano at
a large financial services company up
the street with the green line so if you
need any Financial Services uh help talk
no my name is Keith Ammon uh this will
be my third term on the Commerce
Committee uh and my fifth term in the
house and uh I'm excited about what
we're going to do here in Commerce uh
I'm a software developer by trade and uh
interested in some emerging Technologies
that's one of my interests so looking
everybody good morning uh I'm
representative John pusk from Rockingham
13 which is
Derry uh Derry has 10 reps uh this is my
fourth or fifth term on uh
Commerce uh I've been Vice chair before
and I'm Vice chair again and I know a
significant amount of the folks sitting
on the other side of the room uh and
have known them for many many years and
we've done some great work together I'm
looking forward to working with my
compatriots on the committee who I've
been one with a bunch of years and the
new people and uh I'm not usually this
clerk I am Lisa post and I um cover uh
New Boston Mont bernon and liboro along
with Keith Ammon um we work together
very well um I this is my second term on
Commerce um previously I was on
Recreation and development um my first
term I really enjoy Commerce the reason
why I got on Commerce is because I put a
bill in here and I so enjoyed John
Hunt's um way of making everybody
comfortable and um things were funny and
made it very interesting as well with
all the four um separate um Insurance
baking uh liquor um and and I just find
it a really interesting
um uh committee to be in and so I look
forward to working with everybody again
and thank you very much for being here
today and I look forward to what you
have to say yeah who knew that banking
fun hi I'm Anita Burrows this is my
fourth term my third one in Commerce
unlike chairman hunt I have not been
here since
um but um anyway um the thing I like
about this committee is that it's very
bipartisan I I'm arguably a little
Prejudice I think it's the best
committee to be on um in the state house
because we all get along and we pass a
lot of bills and um there's little of
unusual hi I'm Carrie spear I represent
National Ward three my background is all
Science and
Tech uh and although I have been asked
to be on the science and Tech committee
uh as part of the loyal oppos uh loyal
opposition I chose this committee to be
on it for my second term in loyalty to
John because he runs a really good
committee and I've subbed on all of them
was L Walsh I represent Rockingham 15
the town of Hamstead uh my background
was in Hightech for companies like Wayne
labs and hulet Packard and uh the
continuing OE to John I think that this
is the best Committee in the house and I
too have uh experienced some of the
others uh for sitting in on them or
having bills to present so uh thank you
for allowing me to be on it again and I
look forward to working with everyone
thanks uh my name is Chris melier my
background is in financial services um
I'm also a real estate agent so you can
come to me for all your stuff you don't
need to go to these guys
uh I represent uh uh Carol County
District 2 I live in the beautiful
Village of Jackson New Hampshire and uh
my wife followed me down here uh today
she's going to uh this is this is her
first trip to uh to conquer in the state
house she'll be introduced tomorrow so
you good morning my name is Julie mil I
represent Hillsboro 12 which is marac I
am a medical underwriting registered
nurse and I also work clinically at the
Beth Israel Ley health system as a
nursing supervisor for the house on the
weekends um Kish was my first choice so
I'm very thankful that I landed here I
look forward to working with you all and
um my priorities are healthc care
transparency Pharmacy benefit Clarity
health how's it going my name is Jared
Sullivan I'm the state rep for Grafton 2
which is Bethlehem in Franconia and I
live in Bethlehem uh this is my second
term and I kind of echo what everybody
else says I think it's the best
committee to be on I've sat in and
subbed on other committees and I've
presented bills and uh there's
definitely a lot more animosity and it
seems to be less friendly if you on
another committee so if you if some of
the new people get a chance to go do
that I think you'll see what I mean
after your experience working here uh so
anyways I look forward to meeting
everybody and working working with those
know hi good morning everyone my name is
Santos salvi I live in NASA since
1998 uh I state representative for wari
in Nashua uh by profession by education
I'm a mathematician and a financial
graduate I'm running a company IT
company global company working in four
countries uh I'm a real estate investor
as well uh but mostly the reason I'm
here is I'm social volunteer I do a lot
of community work for last 20 years
currently working with national soup
kitchen with 48 families serving every
Thursday for Last 5 Years 120 to 140
homeless people thank
you great thank you um so we are missing
is it Chris Herbert who no no that's one
there over here okay so we're visiting
Herbert and gibs and Gibbs okay so um so
um in terms of what I'm going to do
today we have I do have a schedule in
terms of the different
departments um but I'm I'm supposed to
to uh give you guys uh especially for
the new members but the old members to
remind you of all the rules and
regulations so the first thing we do is
take out our cell phones and make sure
we have turned off the ringer on your
cell phone um we do have a committee
policy that if your phone rings during a
public hearing you you required to make
your $5 donation to our coffee fund so
be you have been warned
um uh what do I car here um okay you
will have be assigned a drawer there'll
be out here there will be a drawer I
mean that is that drawer is your your
desk your file box your committee
assistant all in one drawer uh so um
that that'll be here so you and please
when you end of the day please don't
leave things on the desks because they
don't know what to do with it and and uh
they they probably get thrown away um in
terms of the committee um we we are uh
10 to eight 10 10 Republicans eight
Democrats and
one of the things unusual that we do on
this committee um and this is this we've
been this Traditions it's been almost 15
years I guess is that we're going to
divide up into
subcommittees and we have three
subcommittees uh so when you hear the
people testify and you can kind of
choose which subcommittee you want to be
on um and the subcommittee choices is uh
is is banking business so that'll be
consumer protection type issues and the
banking issues um then we have the
Liquor Commission and Liquor Commission
um is one of those things that uh that
years and years ago used to go to a
different committee but um because I
passed the direct shipping law the uh
don aitech thought it was a good idea
that all the liquor laws bills come to
this committee so we've had it for a
fair amount of years um and the
marijuana legis ation because we had a
bill that uh related to that the Liquor
Commission would be the enforcement
agency that that's why marijuana now
comes to this committee and I know we
have representative sullon has has a
bill I've seen it already and last but
not least is we have insurance now in
past years we've kind of divided up into
health insurance and property casualty
but we've had less and less PC bills and
more health insurance bills and and it
varies so right now that'll be just one
committee insurance so think in terms of
those three divisions which ones you
want to participate
in three because
look Banking and
business banking businesses
together and then and um so it has
varied somewhat over the years uh and
really is the nature of the bills but I
this this seems to be the model what we
did last term so it worked out pretty
well um
okay public hearings um the big the
amount of public hearing and I guess for
for new members just to emphasize that
this is not the Grand in Inquisition you
um all we're trying to do is someone
comes in the sponsor presents the bill
presents what they're trying to solve
because sometimes like most of the time
the bill doesn't actually do that the
way it's written uh and then it's up to
this committee to sort through that and
um and then people will then get up and
speak for and against it um so you we
have an opportunity to ask questions so
you know your questions really are
you're you're trying to gain information
you're trying to solve things in your
head but please do not try to uh get
into debating with the person who who's
testifying and um try to try to get make
it quick as possible um and not have
long drawn out question questions
representative Herbert's not
here no you're no you're not that bad
but you can you do like the little begin
beginning speech with your question so
um okay um
so you will we have I know there's this
rule 44 you up to you what you do I can
all I can tell you is that historically
this is the way I've always treated it
is that every bill has a grain of Truth
and um even though we're all going to
you know pretty much want to kill the
bill um I don't take up bills the same
day we have that legislation all that
allows us to do that um I always believe
every Bill gets should have 24 hours
before we kill it and uh so so in terms
of in this committee what we do
differently is that that Bill gets more
than 24 hours because any bill that we
have will go to that subcommittee and
that individual subcommittee can then
and thrash over it and or make a quick
decision whichever way it works and and
then that is brought to the full
committee so by the time we get to our
exec session we we have really each
SubCom each bill has had its second by
at the Apple in that subcommittee and
it's had a process to be debated and
discussed so usually in our exec
sessions we are very expeditious in
terms of moving bills out of this
committee um unlike you'll hear from
other committees where they can spend
hours debating a bill which we don't
because we that debate should have
happened on the subcommittee
level uh I guess other than that do you
have any ideas anything else we should
let everybody
know
um I guess the only other thing you know
most most people have been here before
but um we will um have Dem caucuses and
Republican caucuses outside of the
hearings and it's just so that um
Democrats can come to a um some kind of
uh understanding of where we stand and
Republicans will do the same but um last
two years we uh seem to agree on most of
the bills it was it was actually a
little
scary yes no we we did really well um I
tell everybody that we didn't in the two
years we didn't really have any major
floor debates um maybe the marijuana
bill was a floor debate but
but it wasn't that major floor debate so
okay uh being now close to 10:30 we'll
um start in on the insurance
department and we are very lucky to have
the insurance commissioner
here with many of his
cohorts you have an interesting
definition of Lucky Mr
chairman
no so good good morning Mr chairman nice
to see all of you it's great to be back
judging by the number of bills I've seen
assigned to this committee I'm going to
uh be charged rent the amount of time I
think my team and I will be in here but
we're looking forward to it uh as you
mentioned Mr chairman my name is DJ
beton cour I have the pleasure of
serving as the commissioner of the New
Hampshire insurance department I'm
joined by my colleagues Deputy
Commissioner Keith Nyan assistant
commissioner Jason Dexter and in the
back Jennifer Smith our legislative
director along with our subject matter
experts these are the faces that you're
going to see uh throughout the course of
this term on legislation related to
Insurance whether they be bills that the
department has put forward or has asked
all of you to put forward on our behalf
or whether we have come in to testify on
insurance related items that we think
you should have some information or some
background on as you deliberate and
consider what you would like to do
with the bill so I think all of you have
in front of you a slide presentation I'm
going to try to go through that as
quickly as I can the team and I have
split up this presentation so you don't
have to hear me drone on and on you can
hear from them as well so first and
foremost our mission the mission of the
New Hampshire insurance department is to
promote the public good by ensuring the
existence of a safe and competitive
Insurance Marketplace through the
development and enforcement of New
Hampshire's insurance laws we are
committed to doing that in an honest
effective and timely manner what all of
that really means for me is consumer
protection that is at the heart of the
Department's Mission and accomplishing
that mission takes on many different
types of forms whether they be as
mission statement says ensuring good
competitive Insurance markets so that
consumers have a lot of choices that
they can make when they are getting
their coverages ensuring that the
marketplace is competitive I'm a firm
believer in the the free market system
but core to that system is a lot of
competition taking place companies
competing for those covered lives
bringing forth better products more
quality products and ultimately keeping
the premiums affordable for the
consumers so consumer protection is
really as I've said at the heart of our
mission Department overview you can read
about me I'm not that interesting uh
what you should know is the department
currently has 91 full-time in two
part-time staff positions as part of the
budget exercise that Governor senu asked
us to go through this past fall and I
think what the incoming Governor will
hold us to is we're going to be a little
bit Slimmer I think we ended up un
funding three or four positions in two
part-time positions so we are running I
think very
appropriately um lean but having enough
staff to make sure that we are doing the
job that we are supposed to do in an
effective
manner little bit about the department
so the New Hampshire insurance
department was established in
1851 and we have the distinction here in
New Hampshire of being the first state
to create an insurance department so
that's a little interesting trivia for
you as you're having lunch over at the
um Barley House or tandies or whatever
if they ask that question you'll know
1851 New Hampshire was the first uh
you'll see the pertinent statutes before
you as to where the rules and
regulations as they pertain to Insurance
live within the vast world of New
Hampshire
statute as you know we are tasked with
enforcement of the insurance laws of New
Hampshire some of the notable ones too
although I know this will be more of a
focus of your colleagues over on the
Ways and Means Committee but it also
includes the collection of Premium taxes
and fees and then you'll deal with the
second half of this note which is the
regulation of all insurance companies
producers consultants and adjusters when
you hear the word producers by the way
uh you can think of that in terms of
Agents both captive and independent
agents Brokers things of that nature
just to help you a little bit with the
nomenclature so in terms of Revenue and
funding I'll turn it over to my
colleague Jason
Dexter right thank you JJ again my name
is Jason dexer assistant commissioner
over at the insurance department top of
the slide says revenue and funding those
are two different things for the purpose
of this slide revenue is the what the
department collects um for general fund
Revenue to fund State the state budget
uh we do that a couple of different ways
we collect that through premium taxes uh
licensing fees and administrative fines
um we going to talk a little bit more
about licensing later on and then the
second part of that is the funding and
that's the funding of our Department we
are um a self-funded department we do an
administrative assessment each year um
to collect the funds to support our
budget which is roughly $13
million um and then we collect that each
year and if we've underspent our budget
we do a little offset um so last year we
invoiced about 12.6
million that's uh revenue and
funding get this point with the
presentation we're going to get into a
little bit about the what we do in a
little more detail
um first thing on slide six speaks to
licensing we license many different
types of entities including companies
producers
adjusters um and tpas as well Keith's
going to get into that in more detail on
slide 15 um another thing we do on both
our property casual side and our life
and health side is we review form
so if an insurance company wants to put
a new product out into the market that's
going to be an insurance form in the
life and health side that comes to us we
review the form for compliance with our
state laws and regulations they can't
they can't sell it until we say okay uh
on the PNC side of the business they do
a um file and use where they file U they
can move those products into the market
but we do end up reviewing them and if
there are issues we resolve them
with that I'm going to turn it over
to DJ back to you thank you Jason just a
couple of other notes on that so as
Jason mentioned we are a self-funded
agency folks are often curious how that
works the insurance companies doing
business in New Hampshire are assessed
and they are assessed based on a per
capita of the written premium that they
write here in New Hampshire so obviously
the assessment for some companies is
greater than it is for other companies
we were able to uh lower the assessment
upfront coming into the next year it'll
be lower by about half million doll
which in the grand scheme of things of
course is not a ton but at a time when
we are seeing a hardening of insurance
markets and I'll get a little bit more
into that later I think anything that we
can do as a department to signal to
Industry that we're going to work with
them and to assist them to get through
these difficult markets to get through
this difficult per period I think it's a
positive sign not for us but again at
the end of the day it's all geared
towards how can we help the
consumers so in fiscal year 24 we
actually as Jason mentioned rebated back
two companies over $2.7 million it was
the result of us doing a good job of
carefully budgeting and keeping our eye
on the spending within the department we
don't roll any dollars over whatever is
not spent at the end of the fiscal year
again is given back to the companies
because at the end of the day it is
their money and we obviously hope that
the money that is returned they will
apply to finding ways to reduce premiums
for consumers though they're not
it's our first day too we're working out
the Kinks bear with us I so why don't we
jump ahead to uh producer licensing
which is actually a little bit forward
in your presentation deck or if you wish
commissioner we can go directly to I
think it's slide 13 talking about the
National Association of insurance
Commissioners um it's a fairly robust
looking slide this is actually a great
opportunity for us to segue into what it
means to be uh in an industry which is
state-based regulation which is the
insurance industry unlike our
counterparts in uh Financial Services in
um Securities and banking um Insurance
across this country is regulated at the
state level one of the biggest
differences or that people are confused
by is the fact that back in 2010 uh
through the Dodd Frank consumer
protection act there was the creation of
the federal insurance office the federal
insurance office office is not a
regulatory body it's an advisory councel
um that office does provide information
there's a lot of coordination with our
overseas counterparts and other
insurance markets but that is an
Advisory Board um primarily insurance is
regulated at the state level as the
commissioner mentioned previously uh New
Hampshire was the first state insurance
department um we currently license here
in New Hampshire 1,200
28 insurance companies that do business
um additionally there are um know tying
that back to our producers we also
license about
245,000 um Insurance Producers and
adjusters um separating that out we have
115,000 114,000
adjusters back to the neic the neic is
an organization which is the name
suggest the National Association of
insurance Commissioners is an
association of all 50 State Insurance
departments as well as our five US
territories the goal of the association
is to bring uniformity to regulation
across the country um the organization
does that by supporting the insurance
departments with information as well as
we meet annually uh to develop model
laws and develop Financial regulatory
standards um frequently the department
will bring forward bills
um in laws relative to financial
regulated Financial regulation standards
those being model laws that's again
bring uniformity across the country as
we look to entities that not only write
insurance in New Hampshire but every
other state as
well that I'll turn it back to you
commissioner thank you Keith so a couple
of other core things that we do we
provide uh oversight in uh for the
financial health of the companies who
are domiciled here in New Hampshire uh
so we conduct Financial examinations and
Analysis of the companies doing business
in New Hampshire to ensure Financial
solvency makes a lot of sense it's
awfully hard for a company to pay claims
if they are bankrupt so we make sure
that that does not happen we do that too
through Market conduct analysis and
exams of companies doing business in New
Hampshire again to not just look at
their Financial Health but also to
ensure that they are in compliance with
New Hampshire's laws and regulations
Keith talked about the niic just to give
you a little bit of insight as to how
the financial examination piece works
together across 50 states and six or
seven US territories however many there
are so the neic has an accreditation
program that every state goes through
every five years and so what that means
is they'll send their staff into the
department to make sure that the process
that we go through and all of the
analysis that takes place of our
domestic companies is up to appropriate
standard how this works is essentially a
little bit of the full faith in credit
type concept which is we'll do the
financial analysis that deep level dive
of all of the companies domiciled in New
Hampshire which means they're
established here this is their
headquarters and so by virtue of us
having gotten accreditation from the
niic all of the other states know that
they can rely on New Hampshire's
analysis of our domestic companies so
that when those companies want to go and
write in their states they know that
they've got a company that has
appropriate Financial Health and
reserves to pay claims and then vice
versa when a company wants to come in
and write in New Hampshire we know that
the state that they're domiciled in has
done their due diligence on the
financial side of things so the niic is
a pretty important entity insurance is
really the last Bastion of a major
industry in the United States of America
that is predominantly regulated at the
state level the ACA obviously has a
pretty significant impact on the health
insurance side of things but everything
else predominantly handled at the state
level and the NAIC helps for us to
coordinate to make sure that there is
some uniformity so that companies are
not having to deal with a vastly
different Patchwork of regulatory
environments other things that we do is
we investigate and prosecute insurance
fraud so in fiscal year 25 we had
457 referrals to the department opened
up 24 new cases and made 15 submissions
for prosecutions our fraud team works
with the County attorneys we work with
the Attorney General's office and we
work with the US attorney's office my
team will do all of the investigation
they'll put basically the case together
for the prosecutor and then hand it over
the to the prosecutor for his or her
decision as to whether or not they want
to bring the case
forward additionally our enforcement
unit uh conducted looks at the producers
and the companies to make sure that they
are not running a foul of laws and rules
so I kind of distinguish between the two
units this way the Fraud Unit looks at
crimes that may have been committed by
the public to the insurance industry the
enforcement team looks to see that the
insurance industry is not doing anything
that it should should should not do that
is going to impact consumers in fiscal
year 24 our enforcement team
investigated 3113 cases and assessed
$856,000
worth of
fines we also conduct public hearings
including workers compensation premium
rates as well as our annual hearing for
cost drivers in healthcare New
Hampshire just a little bit of
background on workers comp so this year
or excuse me last year we approved the
13th consecutive reduction in workers
compensation rates it was lowered by an
additional 5.6% for
2025 and over the course of that 13-year
period New Hampshire has seen a
65% reduction in our workers
compensation rates which is obviously a
very very positive development for our
business Community I get to make the
announcement every year
truth be told we don't get a ton of
credit for that because we don't deserve
a ton of credit for that the credit
really does go to the business Community
which has taken a lot of steps over the
years to make their workplaces safer to
make the best care available for them so
that God forbid when an injury takes
place at work the person is getting that
care right away in getting back into the
workforce getting back to work more
quickly so it really is a testament to
the responsible nature of New
Hampshire's business community so they
truly do deserve the credit and they're
reaping their uh just rewards for
that next up to protect consumers so our
consumer division takes lead on that
those are seven people in our department
who all day every day that they are at
work are taking in calls from consumers
we get a little over 6,000 calls I think
a year that come into to the consumer
division I'd say about 5,000 of those
6,000 are questions that consumers have
what does this mean in my policy what
does this term mean get a lot of
questions about actual cash value lot of
questions about aftermarket parts a lot
of questions about eobs when you're
talking about health insurance insurance
is complex and as I say all the time
consumers generally know two things
about insurance they pay the premiums
they definitely know that and the policy
is hanging out in the safe or The Shoe
Box in the closet with the rest of the
important papers that they hope they
never have to actually deal with or read
and then something happens in Insurance
unfortunately when you need your
insurance policy it almost certainly
means that something bad has happened
now they're in a heightened level of
stress and they're trying to Wade
through a very complex document that
really and truly they're taking a look
at for the first time and so
unsurprisingly that generates a lot of
questions we take those in we really do
encourage consumers to work with an
independent insurance agent not just so
that they can work with that agent to
get the best premiums
possible an independent agent could look
across the full insurance landscape and
really tailor a set of products that may
work best for that individual or that
individual and their family but also
because that independent agent could be
a great resource to them to help them
again understand some of the more
complex terminology and Provisions
within their policy but for those who
don't work with an agent we are here as
well so 5,000 as I've said are questions
the other thousand or so are formal
complaints against their insurance
company the consumer division did a
really phenomenal job over the course of
the last fiscal year they brought in
over $6 million in consumer restitution
which was Far and Away a record for the
Department
not sure why that is I'll give the
credit to the team they're doing a good
job digging into the issues and being
aggressive on behalf of the consumer uh
which is great but they're obviously
continuing to do their good work and
then in addition we provide expertise
and support that looks like data and
statistical analysis of health care
costs and premiums in New Hampshire we
analyze and administer the ACA as
appropriate which is to say how the
federal government asks us to do it and
then we have laws and rules that promote
financially sound principles and provide
consumer protection again a lot of that
work is done by our consumer division as
Jason thank you DJ just a couple quick
hits on this um slide here where we what
we do a collection of Premium taxes
enforcement penalties and fees we've got
a a a tax department with three
individuals that are focused on um
making making sure the right amount of
taxes is is invoiced and collected they
and then they do a lot of auditing
related to what they've done there um
they also will collect the enforcement
penalties if the those are coming out of
either our enforcement unit or penalties
from for some other late payments or
that sort of item and then
um the the fees are also uh work through
our business unit as well so we have a
team of business units working on that
they're all kind of collaborating
together to make sure we get the right
amount of funds into the department um
as far as uh there's item on here about
participation once say we participated
in the legislative process well here we
are and one of those subcommittees that
represent of hunt will we'll have will
certainly be a big part of that one and
are often over here DJ's going to get
into that in much more detail later and
we already uh covered anyc we jumped
ahead for that so thank you Keith turn
it back to
you very good so in terms of the
department and you the legislature as
those of you who have been on this
committee before know we'll come in and
provide Insurance expertise most of the
time that looks like one of our subject
matter experts coming in and providing
to you some insight and some Reflections
on what they are thinking in terms of
The Proposal before you so we'll do that
testimony we will assist legislative
services with um certainly fiscal notes
drafting from time to time we really do
work incredibly hard to function as a
nonpartisan unbiased resource anytime
that we provide a perspective on
something it is through the lens of what
the Department's mission is now I will
say that in the past there has been what
I think is some Fair criticism uh that
we've come in and officially stated our
position to be neutral that we're just
here to provide some information and
then would proceed to provide testimony
that very clearly made it such that we
were favoring one side or the other I
really am going to try to be far more
upfront and candid about what we think
of some things just so that we're all
being on the level here uh one thing
that I will say is we may initially come
in and have no position on a piece of
legislation chairman hunt as he has uh
has a tendency to do we look at the
thing and say I think as he's already
referenced
earlier I understand what you're trying
to do here but what this bill does
doesn't do that so insurance department
could you please take this and rewrite
the whole thing and get it so that it
does what the sponsor wants it to do and
so we'll go ahead and do that you know
if in the process of that we really do
come around to saying you know this as a
result of this intensive collaboration
with the sponsor with the committee is
now a proposal that we can really get
behind I do want to reserve the right to
change our official position for from
neutral to either uh in support uh or if
the bill takes a different turn with a
series of amendments to switch the
position to being an opposition
depending on which way it goes uh but I
am going to try to be and I've told my
team to really try to be far more
upfront and candid about what the
sentiments of the department are at the
at the outset so some of the folks that
you may see come through depending on
the subject matter uh Doug Bartlett who
is the director of our financial
regulation unit should there be a
proposal that deals with how we monitor
the financial solvency of an insurance
company uh James Fox who is the director
of our property in casualty division
he'll be in if it's a PNC Bill and
Michelle Heaton will be a regular face
that you will see again judging by the
number of bills I've seen coming forward
you'll see her quite a bit but she is
the director of our life and health unit
so all of the health insurance bills
that you'll deal with Michelle will be
here to provide some expertise I think
we hit the financial regulation piece
between Keith and I but there's some
information there for you in writing and
I think we can turn to Keith for a
little bit more of a dive into the
Property and
Casualty thank you commission so really
what I wanted to do is kind of talk
about both structure-wise our Property
and Casualty unit um as the commissioner
mentioned James Fox is the director of
that unit you'll hear from him
frequently our health director Michelle
Heaton you'll hear from her as well both
of the units are structured basically in
the same format in that each unit
oversees a compliance team which again
is the the pre-issue reviewing all the
forms and the applications that
consumers will see kind of a pre-issue
compliance review there's also an
Actuarial component to that so each team
has an Actuarial staff uh that Actuarial
is works with the compliance team and
looking at rates and forms to make sure
that the products are priced according
to our state laws there's also a legal
support unit that supports each division
we refer to those uh attorneys as our
product CLI attorneys um each of those
has an expertise in the whether it be
Financial regulation or um Life and
Health Products or property casualty
products each has an expertise that they
add to their respective product Silo and
then lastly each unit has a market
conduct unit the market conduct unit is
responsible for uh post product issue
enforcement of our laws and regs such
that when our complaint division
identifies a particular issue or
trending practice or or or grievance or
issue within the industry the market
conduct team will go into the companies
essentially doing an operational audit
um looking for systemic practices and
can U work with our enforcement division
to take action against those entities um
so each of those product divisions are
structured in the same way again
focusing on form review um ensuring a
competitive Marketplace um trans
transparency in premium development um
and ultimately holding carriers
accountable for the way they conduct
themselves within our insurance market
and lastly that market conduct team is
also making sure that claims are being
properly so before I get into the life
and health Deep dive with you I
mentioned before that we are working
with
industry to assist them through what I
have termed as to be a hard market and I
just want to Define that very quickly
give you a very quick background as to
what is driving this particular hard
Market purely for the reason that I
think you're probably hearing from a lot
of your constituents complaints about
why their homeowners and auto insurance
is going up let me explain to you a
little bit of what is going on so the
term hard Market is an insurance term
which means that demand for particular
types of coverage is at traditional
levels or higher but access to that
coverage is more restricted it's a basic
Supply demand type Dynamic that where
the access to that coverage is being
tightened the cost for what remains is
obviously higher so why is that
companies are being more careful and
more restrictive as to the types of risk
exposure
that they are exposing themselves to the
reason for that and this is a pretty
unique hard Market are some things that
typically Drive hard markets things like
inflation things like interest rates uh
costs are going up on things now some of
that over time will obviously Abate
inflation will eventually come down
Insurance uh interest rates will
eventually come down but there are some
things that we're going to have to get
comfortable with being here for the long
term so for
example you know we've made great
Innovations in what we put in terms of
Technologies into our vehicles and into
our homes for a long time I'm very cheap
I was driving around in a car that
didn't have air conditioning in it I
didn't want to get it fixed I didn't
need it I rolled the windows down I'm
cheap that way my wife on the other hand
has a car that gives her a back massage
as she's going up 93 she has different
priorities than I do point being is that
back massager is expensive and so when
it breaks it's obviously expensive to
get the parts to fix it the expertise
that's needed to do the work I've
obviously made more of a light-hearted
example there but all of the new safety
features that are now in vehicles and
all of those things are great we want
citizens to be as safe as they possibly
can be in their homes and in their
vehicles but again all of that
technology comes with a cost and I don't
see anyone CL clamoring to go back to
the days of the Model T or the Fred
Flintstone mobile so that technology is
going to be here to stay and so that's
going to be a pretty uh
consistent thing that puts some pressure
on premiums going forward but that's
manageable the thing that is more
difficult for us to directly impact is
that companies are seeing huge losses
across the country for catastrophic
weather events
and we are seeing data that is
undeniable that the frequency and
severity of these storms and they're not
just storms there are other weather
related
catastrophes again not just the
Hurricanes that hit Florida or the Gulf
Coast of the Carolinas it's also the
wildfires that eat up half of California
seemingly at the end of every summer and
beginning of every fall it is some of
those bizarre weather phenomena that
take place in the mid West in the rocky
mountain region all of that creates a
lot of damage and obviously the
companies have to ensure that damage and
it's very very expensive and we're
seeing more of that with greater
frequency and so that is driving some of
this hard Market as well I'm going to be
bringing forward for your consideration
later in the term something that I think
can help homeowners in particular get
through this because none of us
single-handedly have an influence on how
we handle why these weather things are
going on but we can I think bring some
relief to bear and again we'll talk
about that a little bit later so all of
that coming together as one really is
causing a lot of companies to tighten up
on their underwriting number of them
have stopped writing certain lines of
business and so again when you don't
have the same access to the coverages
that you've had in the past it drives up
premiums and so that's why a lot of
folks are saying I don't understand why
my PR premiums went up $100 $200 from
last year I haven't put a claim in in 20
years as much as we like to think we're
the captains of our own destiny here in
New Hampshire insurance is a very
interconnected industry interconnected
across all 50 states but really
internationally speaking particularly
when you're talking about reinsurance
which is also a challenge that a lot of
our insurance carriers are facing having
trouble holding on to their reinsurer or
having their reinsurer in increase their
premiums which obviously has a downshift
cost onto the companies themselves so
some of these things will eventually
fles themselves out um other things
again will have to be prepared for for
the long term but that in a nutshell is
why some of your constituents are seeing
what they're seeing we always always
always encourage consumers again to work
with an independent agent to shop their
coverage New Hampshire despite being a
small state um has over 200 companies
competing for homeowners insurance and
auto insurance coverage here in New
Hampshire so there are options out there
for consumers and again we encourage
them to take advantage of that and to
shop around to see who might be able to
give you a better price for the coverage
that you
need in terms of life and health again
Keith described kind of the model for
how these units work but we'll come in
and talk about things that will impact
the large group Market the small group
Market the individual Market I'm pleased
to say and we touted this quite heavily
that New Hampshire's average Benchmark
premium is
$325 which is the lowest in the nation
per the Kaiser Family Foundation and
wallet Hub who did analysis of that
we're very very proud of that now people
ask how is this
possible many different reasons for it I
think the one that is most pertinent to
all of you in this room is that we are
very careful about the types of burdens
that we put on the backs of our insurers
we obviously want to ensure appropriate
consumer protection we want to ensure
that fundamental coverage is there for
conditions to be sure but we don't
typically see this legislature moving
forward with huge expensive burdensome
mandates and so all of that helps to
keep costs under control we also as a
state work very collaboratively with
industry
the reason being is appreciate the fact
that we have as I've said a very
competitive PNC Market in our individual
market for a state of 1.35 million
people or so we now have four players
competing in that market which is great
we just had a new market entrant for
2025 well since so we now have four
players and representative hunt and I
can remember not all that long ago we
were worried about whether we were going
to see a complete collapse of our
individual Market which is to say all of
the players are going to pull out of the
market but because all of us the
Executive Branch the legislative branch
across the board worked collaboratively
with industry and gave them assurances
that we would work with them and bring
what tools that we had available to Bear
to get them through that rough patch we
not only preserve the market but we set
ourselves up for a lot of success both
in terms of cost and in terms of
additional competition
that next we'll go over to Keith I think
you commissioner so as we talk about
other legislative initiatives we already
mentioned producers and adjusters that
$245,000 uh 245,000
um producers agents Adjusters in the
state of New Hampshire additionally that
particular unit um is also responsible
for um conducting the licensing exam
ation of those agents um as well as the
continuing education of those agents um
with the Advent of and there are other
certain fees that are collected um in
association with those licenses as with
the Advent of Technology there have been
some developments over the last 18
months in particular uh which we have
been able to more efficiently collect
some of those fees so there will be an
introduction of some um bills which will
help see some of those fees reduced um
in in recognition of those technology
advances
it I think we've hit all of the
materials on the next slide so we're
just going to skip over that I don't
want to run too long so the next two
slides are contact information should
you need to get a hold of us some places
where you can direct consumers to some
sites that you can go to for additional
information you know again the last
thing that I'll stress is we really do
try to take a pragmatic and Common Sense
regulatory philosophy at the department
and that's not anything that I can take
particular credit for that is an
attitude and approach is developed in
the department over many many years and
people often ask me you why the
collaboration why try to work with the
companies to solve problems rather than
taking a more heavy regulatory hand and
again the reason for that is appreciate
that New Hampshire represents less than
one half of 1% of the total written
premium in the United States of
America people in the sea Suites in New
York City and Hartford Connecticut are
not sitting in those boardrooms saying
to themselves you know what we've got to
do we've got to somehow break into that
New Hampshire Market there are Untold
Financial windfalls to be had if we can
just get into that New Hampshire Market
no they want to do business in New
Hampshire because we are a good place to
do business we are a good risk as a
state we are a highly educated people we
make good decisions we are a safe state
to be
you see all of the metrics and rankings
that the various organizations put out
in New Hampshire always fares right at
the top of the list in terms of best in
all of those quality of life metrics and
that's the reason that companies want to
do business here and because we do
collaborate with them because I do have
the ability when there are small little
things that come up to pick up the phone
and call the head of that company and
basically say knock it off please and
they do
it helps us to address problems a lot
faster whether they be systematic
problems or whether they be a problem
that's impacting one consumer and we're
able to quickly resolve that problem for
that particular individual that
collaborative approach that pragmatic
Common Sense approach I think has served
not only to best enforce the laws and
the rules that that you all in the
legislature have brought forward over
the years but the department has brought
forward as well
but again it also ensures that consumer
protection mission is being accomplished
in the best manner
possible so with that Mr chairman I'm
happy to take all of your questions I
apologize you know obviously I think
what we do is very very important I'm
never going to be as exciting as the
liquor and the lottery
no it's uh it I think it's important
point out is the diversity and uh and
the importance of all the things that
the department does do that this
committee needs to know about um
question
yes so I have I have two questions uh
you mentioned that you're going to be
more uh proactive I guess maybe that's
not the right word uh give us more
information as to what your really your
opinion is on things and I found that in
the past two years it's
been difficult when you don't give your
opinion so I appreciate that you're
going to do that but one thing I ask
because
by now most of you know how I do stuff I
really would like you to give us the
reasons why you have the position that
you have sure because that'll save me a
few hours in my no I I appreciate that
representative let me say this a unique
moment for me I've I've never been told
that I've been shy to give my opinion on
anything but I I want to know why the
second thing was when we ended last year
and I think this is the right place to
ask the
question uh and if I'm wrong then please
tell me uh and I have been participating
in it the ambulance study so when are we
that really yeah excellent
excellent absolutely yeah we do have
legislation to couple of them couple of
them couple bills yeah so I I yes
represent bars I have two quick
questions one so there I was uh very
torn I was asked to to sign onto an
ambulance uh pricing bill this year and
decline because of that commission so I
take it that was probably a good move
yes okay awesome Yep so just very
briefly for those who are not here or
those who have been here representative
hunt in particular know we have had a
very robust discussion over a very very
long period of time regarding ground
ambulance and at its core the issue is
while there are balance billing
protections at both the state and
federal level for nearly everything in
health insurance these days the Last
Frontier of medical services that do not
have Balan billing protections for
consumers is ground ambulance and how
that comes about is long and short the
ambulance providers in the insurance
carriers are not able to come to an
agreement to get them in network they're
not able to agree as to what the rate
schedule is going to be for the services
that they provide so as a result of that
they're out of network so the insurance
carrier will pay the provider whatever
amount they pay to an outof network
provider so using round numbers for
example let's say you're a commercially
insured individual you need a ride to
the ambulance that ride is
$1,000 the insurance carrier says we
reimburse not out of network providers
$200 and so what happens is the balance
of that the $800 gets shipped off to the
consumer the consumer often times has no
idea what that bill is
for a lot of times it is a financial
stretch for them it's a real burden for
them and they can't understand why this
is happening when they have insurance
coverage uh and so we've tried to over
the years figure out how to address that
and so where we landed at the end of
last session was you all in the legisl
asked the department to conduct an
Actuarial study of what the appropriate
rates should be for commercial insurance
carriers to give to providers for ground
ambulance now appreciate and you'll see
this reflected in the report 80% or so
of ground ambulance rides are for
individuals who get their insurance
coverage through one of the government
programs meaning either Medicare or
Medicaid and as you know those rates are
fixed they're non-negotiable the federal
government sets the Medicare rates they
also set the Medicaid rates the state
has some play in that as well and I
think in the last budget you in fact
increased Medicaid rates for ground
ambulance a bit which was very very
helpful and so what you're left and what
we're talking about are the 20% of those
rides who are from individuals who have
commercial insurance coverage I will
tell you that the report reflects a lot
of what I
hypothesized would be the case when we
first launched this study which is to
say that carriers need to increase their
rates they need to bump those rates up
particularly for providers servicing
areas defined as rural or super rural
because those rides are less frequent
but the distances are longer and the
providers have no less of an obligation
to ensure an appropriate state of
Readiness but also the reality of it is
it's not as much as I think the
providers
want and I think that again it comes
back to what I've said now for quite
some time yes some of the rates need to
increase and that's reflected in the
report but if you want long-term
stability for those ambulance providers
they need need to analyze their current
business model and make adjustments to
their business model because at present
barring again some significant increase
in Medicare or Medicaid rates it's just
not sustainable long term and what I
don't think is fair is for us to say
well because the providers are not
getting what they need from Medicare and
Medicaid to sustain their current
operations what we need to do is to
greatly
increase the costs onto the 20% of the
commercial Market to essentially
subsidize what they're not getting I
don't think that that's fair and again
if you were to go with some of the rates
that some of the providers have
suggested you are going to
see very significant premium increases
for consumers which again is not
something we want to see given the
advantageous position the state
currently sits in having some of the
lowest average monthly premiums in the
nation so that's a little bit of the
background there that's a little bit of
a sneak peek as to what you're going to
see in the report when it comes out this
afternoon further question okay I I I
don't want to go down a rabbit hole but
just a make it a quick question are you
actively involved with the negotiation
between Anthem and St Joseph's
actively I don't know how to define that
exactly so
I'm certainly involved I'm certainly
involved and again I'll give a little
bit of a background although I think
it's been pretty public so Anthem and St
Joseph Hospital in nashille have had a
very very difficult time negotiating a
new contract for St Joe to remain in
network with
Anthem typically and over our history as
a department we very very rarely get
directly involved in a negotiation
between a provider and a carrier number
of different reasons for that not the
least of which is because if you were to
give me some sort of authority to
arbitrate or mediate these disputes uh
we'd have to add an additional unit to
the department to handle all of the
differences of opinion that you know
crop up in these
negotiations um but also because there's
an inherent unfairness in the sense that
when I've got those two parties in the
room I regulate the insurance carrier I
don't regulate the provider and so that
insurance carrier in that Dynamic is at
a disadvantage and that's just not fair
to them in this case however and I'm
very very narrowly defining why we took
the action that we did you can label
this as the veton cord Doctrine if you'd
like uh but obviously Anthem is the
state's largest insurance carrier Nashua
is new Hampshire's second largest
community St Joseph is a huge player in
the not only in nsha but the surrounding
communities as well but the biggest
issue for me was the dispute was coming
at a time when we are on the very tail
end of the open enrollment period And so
a lot of people have made decisions as
to which coverage they've chosen for
themselves and their families on the
assumption that St Joseph hospital will
be in network with Anthem because when
they looked at the different plans they
obviously looked a lot about what the
premium looks like and the deductible
but also what the network looks like
they obviously want to be in network
with the providers that are closest to
them or the providers that they have
long-standing relationships with and so
for
this potential fissure to take place at
this particular time I thought was
pretty problematic and we were hearing
from a number of you senators as well
two Governor's offices uh that they were
very very concerned about this situation
and so later this afternoon
representatives from Anthem and St
Joseph will come over to the department
and I will share with them the resources
that the department has uh that we can
make available to them to hopefully get
them a little bit closer to an agreement
people ask me what those resources are
we have a very comprehensive all claims
database that could potenti po Al be
very helpful we have a data analytics
unit my math nerds as I affectionately
refer to the maass uh who can help
crunch numbers for for them we can be a
neutral Arbiter of information track
some things down so we can be helpful
that way but obviously I do want to
share with them some of what I've been
hearing from citizens and some of what
I've been hearing from you because it
you know this has obviously created a
great deal of anxiety for a lot of
people and again it's a really tough
time for this all to be coming to a head
so I am going to bring them in for a
conversation and hopefully that proves
fruitful in ultimately getting them back
into an
agreement representative pelli has a
question thank you for taking my
question so representative Burrows and I
participated in a short discussion about
one very important issue here in New
Hampshire which is mental health um
accessibility to provider accessibility
and we found out that you already had a
very robust U study group um that was
already looking into that issue so I
wanted to know if you were able and it
was comprehensive you had a lot of
different um organizations and and
resources available so we didn't want to
duplicate that work so I wanted to know
if um your your commission um completed
that work if there was a uh results
published any conclusions and if so
where we could find that information out
sure so the department about a year or
so ago brought back its Behavioral
Health advisory committee and so it's a
standing committee of a broad array of
stakeholders they include the insurance
carriers they include Advocates
providers legislators members of the
public uh who come together and share
with the Department different Trends and
different issues that they are seeing in
terms of access to behavioral health
services and treatments and it drives a
lot of what we focus our attention on
and it also helps us to get some
feedback from them on some different
legislative proposals that you will all
bring forward to us or have a
conversation with us about that you're
thinking about bringing forward no study
per se because that work is ongoing
that's a standing group within the
department and we're not letting those
guys go anytime soon uh but obviously we
did a lot of work work for the
legislature this summer in Fall with the
study committees that you all brought
forward I thought you all did a lot of
good work it was a lot of excellent
information I think we were able to dig
into and better understand together but
if there's a particular issue or
particular concern that you are hearing
from your constituents or you're hearing
in general I'll bring them to me and
I'll put it on the agenda for that
advisory committee to take a look at and
share their perspective and if we need
to do a deeper dive or do additional
work into that issue we will certainly
we will certainly do that I will tell
you that mental health is my number one
priority as commissioner I take it
incredibly
seriously in fact we were successful in
getting a $40,000 Grant from the NAIC
for the Northeast Zone to do a mental
health parody compliance Symposium which
is going to bring together Regulators
from the north northeast states NAIC
defines Northeast as the District of
Columbia all of the states going north
up to Maine and so that will be I think
next week or the week after we're going
to bring all of the mental health Mia
experts together in those States and
share best practices um again I think
over the course of the term we'll talk a
lot about mental health but there are
some areas within Mia compliance that
remain incredibly difficult for
Regulators to get their arms around
particularly the non-quantitative
treatment limits some states have
developed great tools to be able to
assess whether there's parity in those
areas and we want to engage in my
favorite kind of R&D which is to rip off
and
duplicate uh anything that another state
is doing that is working really really
well we want to make sure that we're
bringing that to Bear here in New
Hampshire again to the benefit of the
people of this
state repr Teresa
so I have a um basic question uh based
on the presentation that you gave it
seems like you have two departments one
that takes care of the consumer rights
and consumer
interests and uh protects them and the
second which also helps the insurance
businesses like you know you know
processing their fraud cases and etc etc
I'm sure your department must be getting
Revenue based on because you're helping
them processing those so my question is
that uh you have two divisions one
getting to the interest of consumers and
other getting to the interest of the
businesses how do you walk a fine line
between two div these two divisions
because some of the cases I'm sure it
comes where uh you can be biased either
way or you can make opinion or you can
make judgment uh based on one fight or
the other so how do your department walk
a fine line sure so I I think though the
presentation may have made it appear as
though there are some units within the
department that are siloed off I can
assure you that all of the units work
incredibly well together there's
interconnectivity within everything that
we do as an example you know our
consumer division is obviously the most
public facing unit within the department
in terms of talking with consumers every
day working with the public through
issues but if they begin to see a number
of call s that are coming in related to
the same issue related to the same
carrier that information gets passed
along to one of the units so whether
it's a PNC thing that they're seeing or
whether it's a health insurance thing
that they're seeing it'll get passed off
to that unit and the market conduct
teams within that unit will then take it
and begin to assess whether or not there
needs to be an exam and let me just say
people think that the most uncomfortable
thing that the department can do to an
insurance company is to find them that's
actually not true the most uncomfortable
thing we could do to an insurance
carrier is to put them through a market
conduct exam and what that looks like is
again let's say we've identified a
particular issue taking place with a
particular carrier or a particular set
of carriers we will launch a market
conduct exam and we will embed our
examiners in that company and we will
say we want to see 2500 or so
files picked at
random again targeted a specific issue
and they will go through each and every
one of those files and along the way
they're marking all of the areas where
there have been a violation of state law
or a violation of State Rule and by the
way we charge the companies for the
pleasure of hosting us which can get
very very expensive and then at the end
of that process when we've tallied up
all of the violations that we've
discovered then we find them it could be
a very very expensive proposition now
again I'm being a little bit
light-hearted here the attitude of the
department over many years and my
attitude as commissioner I'm not looking
to be punitive I'm just trying to
correct behavior I'm trying to ensure
that we are addressing the problem or
the experience the negative experience
that the consumer is having sure
we will find companies because we've got
to hold them accountable and we want to
ensure that they are adequately taking
the steps they need to take to fix
whatever it is we've asked them to fix
and it's not just a fine there's a
corrective action plan that will also
accompany the end of an exam as well and
typically what I try to do is to put a
really large fine suspended over that
corrective action plan to say you're
going to have a period of time to make
these changes make sure you make them
because if not over a year or two period
we'll go ahead and assess that full fine
and you're not going to want that um so
we we do really do try to work together
in terms of bias the law is always the
anchor the law is always the tether for
us as a department what does the law
what does the rule set forth and we look
to apply that in the most appropriate
manner possible and so sometimes the
result of that will be something that is
favorable to the company and sometimes
that is a result that will be favorable
to the consumer and if the outcome is
not one that you want to see you always
have the opportunity to bring forward a
piece of legislation to change the law
and if you change the law I'll enforce
that
one fair enough thank you so uh
representative pusk would like the last
word thank you Mr chair um DJ and I go
back along long way uh as
commissioner uh and as uh
a rep in dairy uh Dairy has a lot of
people and we have 10 reps but a lot of
the folks know uh that I deal with
insurance problems in the past two
years uh I've had two
constituents uh notify me that they were
having problems with their insurance
companies I sent out an email to DJ
personally and it was acknowledged
within a half hour that that he would
have somebody take care of it a couple
of days later my constituent got a hold
of me and said I don't know how you did
it but the problem's being taken care of
and this is typical of my contacts with
the insurance people uh they do great
work and uh they do it quickly and my
constituents love you guys so thank you
for the work you're doing well I
appreciate that very much representative
P we take customer service very very
seriously there are advantages and
disadvantages to being a small state I
think one of the advantages that people
should have living in a small state is
that when you have a problem you should
be able to get an individual on the
phone or by email very very quickly to
address your issue we're a small team
but we're very a good team I'm biased of
of course but we really do try to be
very Nimble and turn things around very
very quickly uh for constituents and I'm
glad to get that positive feedback thank
you we that thank you very much thank
you Mr
chairman all right next up is banking
Department
and again we are very privileged to have
good morning good
morning I'll just so I have a handout
that's going around I put a few extras
over
there I don't want to spend a lot of
time going through the handout but it
just gives some high level information
about the banking Department
um good morning for the record my name
is Amelia galerian I'm the bank
commissioner for the State of New
Hampshire this feels very close to me so
I'm going to push it away um it has to
be okay okay I'll put it close um it
won't wait I'm happy to be here to give
you some high level information about
the banking department but most
importantly I'm here to introduce my
team because they will be the people who
you will be seeing and interacting with
and I feel like that's the most
important part that you all know who you
can reach out to at the banking
Department if you have an issue so I'll
get started with that so to my left is
uh Deputy Commissioner Mike moranti he
most frequently will be watching you on
camera he will probably not be here too
much but if you have an issue he's
available to be reached out to but he is
the one who usually is watching the
hearings going in the background uh to
my right is general counsel Seth saraki
he's probably the face you're going to
see the most generally either him or his
Deputy Bob will come in and testify
about legislation on behalf of the
banking department so he's somebody who
you're going to see a lot of um behind
me is uh public information officer Ian
Clark he tracks all of our legislation
for us similarly he will also be
watching on the camera probably won't be
here too too much but he is uh our
primary legislative tracker and always
keeps us well informed about what's
going
on uh and probably watching on camera
right now is Deputy General Council Bob
and birdie who could not be here today
for health reasons but he is another
face who you will be seeing
here um so to look at my hand oh do you
have a question yeah can you make sure
when you're done you can yes the
non-microscopic version yes I can I can
provide that I apologize
really I had it even smaller when it was
a slide in the slideshow and I was like
this is not going to work um so I'm
happy I can provide this whole thing to
you digitally so you can have it thank
you yeah I apologize there's no good way
to give the give the hand out with that
um I apologize so uh to go into the
handout um the first slide is the
mission of the department uh the summary
of that slide is we are consumer
protection focused regulatory agency
that supervises the financial services
sector so we regulate banks credit
unions trust companies and um several
different types of licensed Consumer
Credit entities so money transmitters
think PayPal Western Union we regulate
small loan lenders um which includes
title lenders and payday lenders we
regulate mortgage companies of all
shapes and sizes so Mortgage Services
mortgage brokers Etc um and we regulate
debt adjusters so those are the folks
who negotiate um debt payments on behalf
of
consumers so that's a little bit of our
um Mission um we supervise those
entities in three major ways we conduct
examinations we monitor off-site data
that's submitted To Us by those entities
and we investigate consumer complaints
the next slide talks a little bit gives
a little bit more detail about the
jurisdiction of the department um we
have 45 State chartered trust companies
that regulate 17 State chartered Banks
um we do use the terms licensed and
chartered a lot when we come and present
to you and so um the difference between
a license and a chartered entity is the
license is renew every year so all the
and we have roughly well we have over
7,000 lenses but some of those are
individual mortgage Originators um but
we have about 2,000 is that we are
responsible for examining and take
consumer complaints on
Etc moving right along um I have a slide
that talks pretty high level about
examination our examination and
enforcement Authority additionally
investigating into consumer complaints
um what you you need to know is that
entities that are regulated by us if
they're chartered by us we regul we go
into to examine them about every 18
months there are some exceptions we can
go in sooner if we need to so that's the
banks credit unions and Trust companies
we go in and look at every 18 months
routinely and more often if there's an
issue um we also work with our federal
counterparts a lot so the FDIC the ncua
for credit unions sometimes the cfpb um
all the oh and the Federal Reserve so
all of those Federal entities come in
and do examin with us um the licensed
entities that I talked about the money
transmitters mortgage companies Etc are
um examined every 24 months give or take
unless there's an issue if it's a new
company we go in a little sooner Etc um
when it comes to an enforcement action
there we have several different types of
enforcement actions we do um the main
thing takeaway is that we part of being
I think a good regulator and really
effectively um protecting consumers is
promoting a vibrant Financial Services
sector so that the companies they have
lots of options of who they can go to
and that they're safe and well regulated
um so we try not to be punitive we try
to work with companies to bring them
into compliance that's really the goal
of any sort of enforcement action that
we do um you can get a flavor for the
enforcement actions on our website
they're all public um we did revamp our
website in the last couple of years and
it's very user friendly I think or at
least much more than it used to be so
that's the examination enforcement um
slide we also have a slide about how the
bank Bing department is funded in a
nutshell we're a self-funded agency so
we get an appropriation from the
legislature and then over the course of
the fiscal year we collect fines and
fees and at the end of the year an
assessment if we need to to um pay back
that appropriation
essentially that's that slide um we also
have a strategic plan which I put on
here again it's microscopic I apologize
but I did include our website where you
can go read the full thing um it also
it's the 20 it ends in 2025 so we're
getting ready to do a new strategic plan
um and you can go and look it we've
tried to update it as we go the version
on our website so you can see what we've
accomplished on that strategic plan so I
think that's I'm pretty proud of that um
in terms of upcoming and ongoing
initiatives right now we're obviously
developing our budget um we've submitted
it and we're obviously working we worked
with Governor sununu's team and now um
governor elect aot's team te to uh move
forward with a budget submission um
we're going to do ongoing legislative
tracking we don't have any um
legislative initiatives that were
promoting this year but we will be in
here on other things that I'm sure you
will hear about from the various
interest groups I believe the banking uh
Association has one as well as the
credit union Association so we will be
in here testifying about those and
others I'm sure um another big
initiative that we're undertaking is
modernization of the banking
Department's um Data Systems
so we became fully well so first we
reduced our office footprint to save
money so then we got rid of all of our
paper files and went paperless and now
we're trying to move off of antiquated
like Microsoft Access databases and into
something slightly more modern perhaps
moving into the 201s of SharePoint so we
are we have that modernization effort
well underway and it feels really good
to be moving in that direction so that's
a big initiative um that we're working
really hard at um and additionally I
always put a plugin whenever I go out
into the world that we are recruiting um
because we are always recruiting even
when we don't have open positions we're
trying to recruit um I think we do
important work it's a good team to work
with it's one of the good things that I
think about the banking department is
not only we have a hard job we have a
serious job an important job but we got
also are a good team to work with so
plug in for my people and also if you
know an attorney send them our way thank
you um so that's kind of at a very very
high level um I don't want to slow down
the works here I'm happy to answer any
questions
um thank you uh we yes represent spe
this is just for my own information
because sry this is my own information
because I just don't know enough about
this do you have any jurisdiction with
respect to National Banks and anything
that they do not really okay um so they
are regulated by the OCC or the FDIC or
the F frb depending on their choices
that they've made in terms of Regulation
um we will take a we if we get a
Consumer complaint about them we do
forward them to the OCC um that's really
the extent of our Authority we don't
have any real enforcement authority over
them or anything like that because you
usually get one or two bills that tell
us we should do something to them but I
didn't think we had any access to be
able to do that no that I mean it would
depend on the nature of the bill but
there is a lot of federal law regulating
them they're heavily regulated obviously
entities um so you do have to watch out
for preemption issues but it would
depend on what it
is so we like State Ted Banks we do like
State Char Banks good because then then
we can regulate
them anybody else have a question
yes yeah uh do you have any uh details
on the mobile banking frauds because
there are those frauds are going up
overall right so I I really like to see
the legislation or any kind of policies
you have the directions you need to give
in any of your website or wherever we
can see it because I have experienced
that and many consumers are experiencing
it because they are not very
knowledgeable and we are not giving
enough guidelines to them so I would
like to see some kind of a
more Deep dive in that area and I would
like just let me know if you have it and
I can give some kind of a inputs with
little bit of my experience yeah that
that would be great so um one of the
things that you'll see in our strategic
plan if you go and look at it is we're
trying to increase our consumer Outreach
so we're always looking for educa
financial education opportunities to go
out into the community and work with
people and provide education so I would
love to speak with you offline um about
anything you know any ideas you have for
that that um right now our current
education so uh oops I'm drawing a Brank
on whether it's February or April I
don't know quite why April Financial
Empowerment month April wow um I
apologize April is financial empowerment
month so um right now our focus is on um
kind of educating young people in
financial services but we've also done
outreaches to elderly through um working
with the um Meals on Wheels and Ian is
actually our Point person on the
Outreach efforts as well
so I would love to if there's a target
audience that needs Financial education
I always want to hear about it so please
I would like to see what kind of uh
content you have first yeah like if it
is like needs to be modified or needs to
absolutely because that's very important
right now those things are getting
changed and the people who wants to hack
the system they are really going after
the people who doesn't know much about
it and the money is money if it's gone
it's gone it's gone yeah it's a
challenge so that is something we
actively deal with um we um did some
legislation a few years ago with the
bankers Association to have a um
vulnerable person's um Financial abuse
Reporting System put into place um we
just get copied on those because
unfortunately we don't have jurisdiction
over the bad actor because usually the
bank helps the consumer identify it and
then they have to report it to law
enforcement but now we get copied on all
of those so we do have some insight into
that um but those are fraud and you know
abusive we'll take it offline yeah
absolutely I'm happy
to and also some of those issues are
addressed by the consumer protection act
yeah depending on the nature in terms of
afternoon any other
questions yes represent mcky uh yes
under the uh how the banking department
is funded you've got two buckets
I honestly don't know what CCD means oh
I'm sorry maybe I took that a it's
consumer credit okay Consumer Credit
Division and then on your uh your your
people page s so13 what does that refer
oh that's um how the state characterizes
each position this is we have so many
different orc charts to choose from I
apologize it it connects to the division
of personnel for their job titles okay
thank you occupational codes he used to
work at dop there this um what's the s
standard occupational codes got
you actually while you're still here
okay um so to talk about the two
departments we just heard from the
insurance department and the banking
Department uh and you would say gee you
know well how how did it come to be that
these are Commerce because at one point
in time this was just known as the banks
committee you have picture of the old
Bank committee and so I would emphasize
the the name that we don't say too often
and that is consumer protection is our
charge and um this
committee uh it's getting on about 20
years ago um had a uh a train wreck of
around the issue of consumer
protection and because we have a
consumer protection
statute uh but that in that statute uh
um we had four
exemptions banking Insurance Securities
and public
utilities and the question then comes
into who was in who is covered and who
was not
covered uh the train wreck actually kill
a aot was attorney general at the time
and uh and and the issue was that a
lensey which was auto
dealers claimed that they were exempt
from the consumer protection act because
they were licensed by the bank
Department to do
mortgage
documents so at that point in time we
knew we had we had a problem because
that was not the intent of legisl we
knew we had to to fix this and uh this
committee this Commerce Committee came
up with a
solution and the solution was does the
commissioner whether the bank Insurance
Public Utilities or Securities do they
have the power of
restitution for the consumer if the
consumer being get
screwed lightly that we want them to be
able to make the consumer whole and
that's really what the consumer
protection act its purpose is and we'll
be discussing that in the afternoon but
it's important I I want to bring back to
the fact that the two departments I
would say the the banking Department was
really easy we got that the consumer
protect adding consumer protection into
their statute was a piece of cake
insurance was not they they they left
the room so I could say this right they
it was a it was a long drawn out fight
um the public utilities companies uh
country uh companies always had it um
because it was called
expungement and which I love that word
but no we don't we didn't we weren't
going to pick that word up that was a
20th century you know 19th century word
um and and securities had it when the
division was created so uh when when DJ
says it was amazed about how much
consumer protection they uh that he was
able to able to enforce um and but that
that uh the reality is that
legislation's only been around for 20
years for the insurance department but
it's important to understand that when
we talk about this balance that you're
talking about the question you asked how
do you well think about the Liquor
Commission they're enforcement and
they're also selling okay so so they
have that Balancing Act also which we we
will regulate but uh it's important for
everyone to understand that the how
these two uh why they're here why
they're in our committee uh because we
are consumer protection and we were are
o oversight and ensuring that both the
banking and insurance departments are up
requirements for Budget purposes to were
under the justice and public protection
section so it all it all kind of makes
sense when you look at it like that
right perfect and with that will thank
you very much and actually do we have
anybody in the banking Department I was
going to do this with the insurance
department but we had too many questions
but is any any you we're all set with
you guys is there any I don't actually
but we we have one person who who's a
lobbyist who cares about banking issues
who
will oh yes okay right and we have
credit credit bureaus right mean Credit
Unions excuse me so uh why don't you
guys you know each get up and just you
know yeah I guess you have to come to
the mic
yeah
sorry this is actually a very
interesting Dynamic that we have here in
the state of New Hampshire and that is
um that in terms of the different types
of financial institutions in the State
uh we have Banks and we have credit
unions and of course we ha St Mary's
which is the oldest Credit Union in the
country uh and then we have our
financial banks that are that have
obviously thrived and done well in the
state of New Hampshire so they these are
the lobbyists that will represent the
two of them so let them introduce
themselves ladies
first good morning Mr chair members of
the committee my name is Gina Powers I'm
the director of government relations at
wrath young and Pignatelli here in
conquered New Hampshire um our offices
are above Citizens Bank on Main Street
um so you'll be seeing um a lot of me in
this committee but as the chairman
indicated one of the um industries that
we represent um is the Cooperative
Credit Union Association and as the
commissioner alluded um we do have one
piece of legislation that will be coming
uh before you um is starting in the
Senate but it has to do with
compensation for um Credit Union board
members it would enable credit unions
should they choose to um pay their board
members so thank you because they are
supposed to be nonprofits right they are
nonprofits
yes thank you chairman hunt and uh
members of the committee for the record
uh my name is Ryan hail vice president
government relations for the New
Hampshire Bankers Association we have 40
member banks uh consisting of State
Charter Banks out of state chartered
Banks so Banks chartered in other states
such as Maine Vermont Massachusetts and
we actually have a New York bank and our
ational Charter Banks um been with the
association for just over six years now
um and I'll be in front of you quite a
bit this this session um supporting
legislation that we put forward over in
the Senate that has to do with uh State
Charter Banks ability to lend um as well
as new chartered Banks um and I will
boast that uh for New Hampshire we have
a very robust um new uh it's called the
noo uh uh environment here in New
Hampshire we've had had quite a few
denovos uh uh Charter here over the past
uh say 16 years explain what it that
means so denovo is when a bank um starts
up um they're put into denovo status
they're and it's a heighten level of
scrutiny with The Regulators um and so
it they after a certain period of time
they come out of denovo status um so
actually the bill that's over in the
Senate uh ties our denovo status to uh
the FDIC since State Charter banks have
both the banking Department as well as
the FDIC as their as their regulator um
I do have a handout for the committee
that kind of gives a overview of how the
industry is regulated as well as our
priorities um and I've included my
business card with all my contact
information our office is right across
street from the state house just to the
right of den not uh of uh Rebel Stokes
so when you're coming to get a coffee
feel free to swing on in we're second
floor
come on in and uh happy to have a
conversation so we're here as a resource
if you do have any questions uh concerns
please feel free to reach out at any
point happy to read that resource for
you when it comes to banking related
issues great questions from committee
members sitting on thank you very much
thank you and
um I guess the last thing I want to say
about again these two and and really is
that um and re Sur say get to your kind
of question is the fundamental issue of
consumer protection is obviously
restitution to to the to uh the consumer
but in terms of what our agencies do is
their responsibility is
solvency okay that we want to make sure
that and and I you know and DJ did
mention it and the bank commissioner
mentioned is that that yes solvency is
important and even like when that denovo
issue um you know we someone started up
we got to make sure that they really
have uh the wherewithal to be in the
business and be leny and uh so you will
I would always say that we were in New
Hampshire was the first state to to have
an insurance department and the reason
why the insurance department was created
and I didn't realize until I read tip
O'Neil's book was the that was the major
issue even in Washington which was
solvency was could an insurance company
make a promise sell you say sell you
product life insurance and then really
be there when you died and whether they
really did Cover the the policy and
solvency is very important so at the end
of the day that um you will see that
consistency of consumer protection is
not only just consumer protecting but
part of that consumer protecting is
ensuring that the company is solvent and
and and won't
won't leave uh leave people high and dry
with that um we'll break for lunch um
and uh I would say that just so you all
know I I usually go to tandies for lunch
so it's my my my watering hle um but
that otherwise I assume the cafeteria is
open I don't anybody know cafeteria is
open and then I do know that some people
bring lunch
um and we'll be back at
1:15 all right
thank
you
e
okay why don't we start out with
afternoon
afternoon and you just put sure let me
mistake hi everyone I am marann Dempsey
I'm the director of the charitable trust
unit for the New Hampshire Department of
Justice with me today is Jared Davis the
assistant director um we were asked
twice if we were the Liquor Commission I
apologize we are not they seem to be the
Preferred Guest of the afternoon but um
but it's a pleasure for us to be here we
are both fairly new to our role so for
any of the new members on the committee
um um we will be learning through this
session in terms of the charitable trust
as as well as you and we look forward to
it I was head of the Civil Bureau a
number of years ago and have come back
to doj so um I have learned in a short
time that charitable trust does a lot um
and that a number of your constituents
will reach out to you um about
nonprofits that they are on or hospitals
in their area and we are happy to speak
to any of you and as well as them
directly we have um three main roles um
in the charitable trust unit one is um
regulatory all nonprofits who conduct
business in the state both inst State
and out of state are required to be
registered with the charitable trust
unit um our unit I'll give you some of
the history that our predecessors would
would impart which is we were the first
um dedicated attorney general unit for
charitable trusts in the country and 43
states have modeled their programs after
ours um so we that's great some trivia
there you go I never knew that yep but
we have about 12,000 Charities that are
registered with us about 7,000 are in
state and then about 5,000 out of state
so once a charity registers with us they
then file annual reports with us so
there's a fair amount of paper and um
that we're working through on a yearly
basis and we have a a small but
dedicated team that does that um so when
folks are doing that filing I think a
very important part for us is the
education and the handholding that we
try to do through that process um folks
can either file it online or in paper
but the people who are working on or
working on Boards of nonprofits are
volunteers and so we try to be mindful
of that that the work that they're doing
is in addition to other obligations that
they have and it can be a complicated
process like any filings can be with an
agency and so we spend a fair amount of
time um our team answering calls and
responding to emails and I'm happy to
get this committee Jared's contact my
direct contact but also just the general
information about our unit and how
citizens can get in touch with us
because we do see one of our major roles
is helping individuals um to be able to
conduct the charitable work that that
they do um the other um big component of
the work that we do is education um we
have a number of materials and resources
and we speak to a number of groups
regarding not just the obligations of
being on a board and what that entails
but we also um do a number of
presentations with
municipalities about um Library trusts
um someone I had met is a trustee for
their for their Town um and so we work
with municipalities on a regular basis
with the filings that they have to do um
with our office the last major component
that we do is enforcement and what that
means is when we get a complaint that a
charity hasn't been properly registered
with us or something more serious in
terms of a theft or or misdoings of a
particular charity um we have common law
and we have statutory authority to
investigate that and to bring action on
behalf of the public
so that is a major role that that we
have it also ties into our education one
of the things we're working on this year
is materials related to Good Financial
governance for our boards so that they
can understand the importance of the
funds that they're holding for the
public and how to make prevent um theft
from occurring so those are some of the
things we work on some of you may have
seen a small article about about the
sale of Catholic Medical Center
yesterday little little thing small
small news um our office um oversees the
healthc care charitable trusts in New
Hampshire so they include the
nonprofit hospitals but they also
include senior assisted living
facilities um and other um Health Care
um hospice centers and things of that
nature so when there is an acquisition
like that happen is about to happen HCA
acquiring a nonprofit um both the
charitable trust unit as well as
Brandon's unit of the consumer
protection division we have statutory
review over those um over those proposed
Acquisitions and and they're big they're
complex they're timec consuming but
they're important and what this
legislature has given us is a clear
mandate to make sure that the citizens
have public information about what is
happening a right to contact the
Department of Justice um and that they
have access to to the information to
understand um what will be happening so
that is a major role that that we do um
because Healthcare entities are changing
all the time not just hospitals but um
because of financial situations and
because of efficiencies different groups
are are constantly um changing hands and
so we we usually have one of those
Acquisitions that we're reviewing at any
at any
time another area of the work that we do
um is Charter Schools which are
nonprofits we work with our new um the
New Hampshire Department of Education um
and in my short time in my role I think
we're realizing the importance I talked
about that strong financial governance
um and we want to make sure that these
schools are off to a good start so we've
built some good relationships that we
want to build on this year with the
Department of Education to make sure um
that obviously these schools are in good
good standing not with educa not just
with education but with our office as
well we want them to be successful and
obviously there's a difficulty if a
school is to go under and you know kids
aren't graduating so that um is an area
that that I think we are spending more
um trying to focus on more this year and
coordinate with our state Partners a
number of our Charities participate in
charitable gaming um and that is
overseen by the Lottery Commission but
we do work with lottery in that regard
as well um and some of our other state
Partners um are Health and Human
Services obviously with respect to the
health care but also the insurance
department um assisted living and and
entities of that nature are considered
Insurance products so when there's going
going to be a change we work with our
colleagues in the insurance department
as well um conservation easements when
we have nothing else to do um we we
dabble into um conservation easements
the the courts have determined that um
when a landowner sets aside property to
be preserved for the environment um that
that is a charitable trust and so our
office will review any request to modify
that um and we oversee that um we also
get involved in litigation not just the
enforcement that I spoke of but when um
when someone um leaves um passes away
and leaves in their will or or sets up a
trust um money to go to a charity
depending on the amount of that our
office will get involved to make sure
that it's handled properly through the
courts and that the money gets to its
intended um charitable donation so we
have a number of Court actions at any
time and um also changes that need to
happen because when people plan to give
money they're doing it in the year that
they do it and things change and laws
change and so sometimes what they
intended or groups they intended to give
it to don't exist anymore and so we work
um pretty collaboratively in terms of
litigation it's a it's a new thing
coming from a civil defense world where
folks will actually reach out to us
before they file something and they will
want um to to get our insight and to get
you know hopefully even our our positive
feedback um before they file something
with the court so that is a very quick
overview of of the work that we do but I
am more than happy to answer any
questions and I look forward to working
with all of you this legislative session
great I'm so glad you came in and gave
us the review representative melair
question thank you very much um I
thought I heard you mention that you're
doing courses for the trustees of trust
funds I know Terry nolles used to do
that he's the Terry nolles of today oh
that's what I'm thinking but but I I I
heard that you had stopped them so we um
partly true I am not the Terry knows we
um Terry um we have had longstanding
amazing historians such as Terry NOS who
has worked with all of the cities and
towns in the state we are rebuilding the
Terry NOS knowledge base and so we are
not doing the number of seminars but we
have been working with
municipalities um in terms of starting
to go back and to give some
presentations but I will tell you we are
rebuilding that knowledge base well I I
hope you would inform us when uh when
you're going to do one of those yeah
absolutely absolutely and I know know um
I mentioned to to representative m m um
that Amy Nichols is our financial
investigator who deals with works with
municipalities but she has been doing an
amazing job of connecting with Library
trustees and really kind of reaching
doing more direct Outreach um you know
we talked about people who are on boards
and it's voluntary the same for the
folks who are doing the work for their
municipalities so AB absolutely yeah
it'd be great you just send us the you
know
email addresses and contact information
um so when she was discussing the
hospital merges that legislation was
crafted in this committee room uh so
that's one of the reasons why she's here
is because obviously it's issue that is
going on um we also did The Prudent
investor and also the bylaw changes
about how to have the conflict of
interests all those bills came through
this committee yeah so that's why it's
very much a consumer protection issue in
appropriate for this committee um did I
see a hand up representative Bros and
then represent I have two quick
questions um one of one of is are County
purview no per per se you know but we
have been it depends on so they're not
it they're not nonprofits set set up but
I will give the example of exitor
hospital when there was a limitation on
services that they were going to put in
place it was impacting um the Rockingham
County nursing home and so you know when
things are impacting communities like
that we're in contact with them we're
involved with them but they are not they
don't file um annual reports with us so
quick followup to that then I have
another question so if there was if you
if there was evidence of financial
mismanagement just incompetence that
doesn't you don't deal with that at all
I think it would be at your county level
that that reporting that that concern
would would occur it well that that's
going into deaf ears but that's another
story um it would not have a little
conflict of interests there the county I
mean I district attorney might I have a
followup question um if there's let's
say that there's a local nonprofit who
is not F following their own bylaws do
you get involved with that we we do and
it depends it's it depends on the level
but that's that is a common
complaint that we get that people
sometimes they set up very complicated
bylaws and then they just realize they
aren't worth necessarily following but
they never actually Chang them and so
that is what we call as board governance
and so when we get aware of situations
where where boards are not kind of
following their bylaws or there's
concerns about that we do we do we start
in an education mode um and reach out
and see if we can um sometimes we'll sit
in on a meeting and we'll listen but
that is something that we would get
involved and and just a a comment um I I
have utmost respect for Terry nolles and
her knowledge but she did once call me
into her office as a as a board chair
and made me cry but I forgive her well
now I have a new goal not to make anyone
cry thank
you okay repres H thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking our questions um
you mentioned the hospital acquisition
and I if I recall that's a case of a
profit for-profit business acquiring a
nonprofit business I was just curious
are extra complications with that
scenario and just briefly thank you yeah
yeah um yes it is um you know it it's
the same statute it's it's it's the same
review but when a for profit takes over
a hospital they don't come within the
direct purview of the charitable trust
any longer that being said the agreement
that that from the report we issued
yesterday is that you know there's
conditions that exist for a 10-year
period that they would still be subject
to but it is it is different and and we
have to look at the fact that they won't
be a charitable trust anymore right but
and more important is the assets do not
you they can't acquire the netw wor the
assets the trust and that uh and when
Anthem uh changed its uh Charter they
actually had to uh pay to the create a
foundation yeah so so we would if there
were a for-profit buying nonprofit the
assets of the nonprofit that cash value
their Book value um has to go to a
nonprofit it has to create a charitable
trust it's a great it's a great point
and it's not just a hospital acquisition
but when a nonprofit dissolves and stops
doing business it has to give its um any
assets it has to another nonprofit or to
a governmental entity so we're working
with um entities to make sure that that
happens but that's right um cmc's assets
or restricted donations would not go to
to the health
HCA thank you very much yeah thank
you
okay so who whose title is in our title
consumer
protection go right yes you're good to
go
okay morning everybody uh I recognize
many of you uh seeing a few of you for
the first time for those who I haven't
interacted with before my name is
Brandon Gad I am a senior Assistant
Attorney General and the chief of the
consumer protection and anti trust
Bureau at the Department of Justice um I
have been in this role for I think seven
years this July before that I headed the
Department's elder abuse and financial
exploitation unit which is part of the
bureau prior to that I was a criminal
prosecutor uh for various counties here
in New Hampshire so I always like to
take this time to you know accomplish
two things the first is to give you all
a super high level overview of what the
consumer protection antitrust Bureau
does and the second is to give you all a
preview of the types of testimony that
you are likely to hear from me um pretty
much every single week for the entirety
of this session unless I decide to send
somebody else but the testimony should
be the same either way so similar to
what Maryann said um the Consumer
Protection Bureau like every division of
the Attorney General's office and
probably every vision of you know most
state government is very very busy and
handles way more than you would think um
if we were to more accurately describe
the bureau it would go from the consumer
protection antitrust Bureau to the
consumer protection and antitrust and
elder abuse and tobacco and data privacy
and condominium and Health Club
registration and miscellaneous Bureau
but you know that doesn't fit as neatly
on a business card so here we are um at
the Crux of what we do though is enforce
New Hampshire's consumer protection act
which is RSA
358a which makes it unlawful for those
in the state who engage in trade or
Commerce to engage in what are defined
as unfair and deceptive Acts or
practices and what that means is um two
different things there are a number of
statutes including the consumer
protection act that have specifically
said certain conduct is an unfair
deceptive actor practice and is a
violation of the statute um some like
really simple examples of that are if
you are selling something and you are
making claims about the quality of what
you're selling or the materials that are
built into what you are selling or the
performance of what you are selling and
you don't have any basis for making
those claims um that's an unfair
deceptive actor practice uh another like
very specific New Hampshire only unfair
and deceptive actor practice that you
know this legislature put into an effect
in response to events in the state um
failure to deliver um heating fuel if
you have a prepaid contract for heating
fuel that's per se an unfair and
deceptive actor practice um and there
are a number of examples both in the
statute and elsewhere throughout the
rsas um where conduct that is engaged in
in trade or Commerce is specifically
defined as an unfair and deceptive actor
practice um a recent example I mentioned
data privacy beginning January 1 um
there's a a comprehensive data privacy
statute that was enacted by the
legislature last year um now affords you
know sign ific rights to New Hampshire
citizens in terms of knowing about how
companies are managing their data um
using their data selling their data for
targeted advertising and having the
right to you know request copies of it
request deletion to opt out of targeted
advertising any violation of that I
think it's about a 10 page statute is an
unfair deceptive actor practice and a
violation of the consumer protection act
but it also gives us broad authority to
look at any conduct in trade or Commerce
that rises to a certain level and this
is a you know a legal determination that
we and the courts you know are are
constantly trying to make what where
this level is um it's called you know we
call it the rascality test which is a
Preposterous name because nobody knows
what it means but the way to think about
it is is the conduct sufficiently bad
like is the thing that was done
sufficiently bad that it's worse than
you would expect to see or worse than
you know a general dispute that would
occur in a specific area of trade or
Commerce and like a good example of that
is uh a breach of contract you know you
hire somebody to build a house for you
you pay them to build a house for you
they build the house for you but it
doesn't meet the specifications of the G
the agreement that you reached with the
contractor it's not the quality it's not
the materials they just didn't do a good
enough job that's a breach of contract
that's not a violation of the consumer
protection act that's something that
would be pursued by an individual in a
civil court on their own however in that
same scenario if you pay a contractor to
build a house for you you contractor
never shows up and spends all the money
on somebody else's job or spends all the
money on themselves and you don't get
the house and you don't get the money
back that's an unfair deceptive actor
practice that's bad enough that rises to
that level of rascality where we would
have the authority um to investigate and
to bring an enforcement action to do a
number of different things so we have
both civil and criminal Authority um and
investigative tools to a try to
determine whether a violation exists and
B if we determine that it has to decide
whether whether it's more appropriate to
sue the business um through a civil
enforcement action or if it's bad enough
to actually bring criminal charges to
seek incarceration and a criminal
conviction based on the conduct um you
that that those types of Remedies you
know both give us the ability to do two
really important things one is to stop
the conduct whether it's through a civil
injunction or through a a criminal order
and two is to get restitution for folks
who are wronged by this bad conduct um
everything we almost everything we do in
Consumer Protection Bureau is you know
oriented towards stopping bad conduct
that protects the public from future
harm as well as getting money back
putting people in the place that they
would have been but for the bad conduct
that already
existed so that's like that's our
consumer protection enforcement we also
you know uh maryan already previewed
this a little bit but any time there is
a combination of two businesses in the
state of New Hampshire um we have the
authority to look at it under antitrust
statutes which um you know most
frequently at least lately has uh been
in the context of the healthcare
industry two hospitals trying to come
together so Marian's review is separate
from the consumer protection bureau's
review our review is focused
specifically on whether the combination
as it's proposed um is likely to result
in a loss of competition that would lead
to higher prices loss of quality loss of
consumer choice um and so we review um
Healthcare mergers and conceivably you
know other mergers although it's been
all Healthcare lately um using that
statute and if we determine that a
combination does rise to that level
where it is a violation of any trust
laws um and could result in the loss of
competition in higher prices we have the
ability a to bring an action to block
that transaction which is a very very
high burden to meet you know anytime the
government is intervening in a private
business deal it should be a very high
burden for the government to come in and
completely undo that more often than not
though what happens if we can is to to
work with the parties to negotiate a
resolution that mitigates the the harm
that we anticipate happening if the the
deal was Consolidated which is what you
saw yesterday in the Catholic Medical
Center HCA Healthcare deal um The Bureau
also very quickly does there's an elder
abuse and financial exploitation unit um
that was the first role that I had when
I came to the Attorney General's office
that is a purely Criminal unit housed
within the Consumer Protection Bureau
investigates and prosecutes criminally
the worst cases of elder abuse neglect
and financial exploitation in the state
also serves a really important function
of supporting local law enforcement and
local County attorneys offices to ensure
that they feel empowered and supported
in bringing those cases because we can't
do them all um and we have done a great
deal of work in building up our county
attorney's offices as well as our local
law enforcement to know how to
investigate these and not be afraid to
bring um really difficult cases that
often involve a victim who unfortunately
is not able to testify um or is no
longer with us by the time we get to
trial um so that's super super high
level what the consumer protection and
anti trust Bureau does out of respect
for everybody else's time you know if
there are any other specific questions
about what we do I I'll take questions
at the end but I wanted to as I said in
the beginning to preview for you all
like the types of things that you can
expect to hear from me um or my
colleagues for the duration of this
legislative session and I think this
really two critical things that I find
myself constantly over here providing
feedback to you all on when there's a a
bill in front of you usually that is
looking to add something on to the
consumer protection act because it
really is the easiest mechanism um if
you want to make something unlawful and
you want to have state enforcement of
something and it's not something that is
specifically regulated um by another
state agency like the banking commission
or the insurance department make it an
unfair and decep actor practice as
defined you know in the consumer
protection act that's frequently the
mechanism that's used and so I think
probably the most important thing to
consider um and that you'll hear from me
routinely is that you know it is
tempting and it's you know often easy to
Simply say something is an unfair and
deceptive act or practice and it will be
enforced by the Attorney General's
office but depending on what that thing
is um a lot of the time it has the
potential to significantly increase the
number of cases that we have to bring
the amount of work that we have to do
the number of Investigations that have
to be done and the number of litigation
matters that the Attorney General's
office has to bring and that often will
necessitate additional resources in
order to fulfill that goal um we don't
want to see bills passed that we don't
have the ability logistically to enforce
on the other side so I I frequently and
not always you know I think that there
are amendments that can be made that you
know we are fairly well resourced um we
we got new resources for data privacy
we're trying to build up a specific unit
just for that but sometimes and
frequently there will be you know
something that has the potential to you
know double the number of complaints
that re we receive and I think it's
important to consider those types of
things and will frequently remind you of
the importance of considering those
types of things um throughout this
legislative session the other probably
equally as important is
enforceability um you know I think that
it's great to to pass a bill
um that lays out that something is
unlawful um but you have to make sure
that we actually have the ability to do
what the bill is intending that we're
going to do and you know the the lens
that I think is most valuable to to
consider that from is you know if the
Attorney General's office on the other
side of a bill being passed and being
written into law receives a complaint
from a consumer that says hey a business
is violating this statute we want the
Attorney General's office to do
something about it does the language of
the bill as put into law give give us
the ability to prove that case to
investigate that case and the problem
that often comes up is if language is
too broad or there's no way to clearly
show that somebody's doing a certain
thing or you know that somebody has
acted in a certain way if the language
doesn't clearly Define that it makes it
very difficult sometimes um if not
impossible sometimes for us to enforce
language the way it's drafted so I think
you can expect to hear from me
throughout this legislative session if
there are issues in terms of the
enforceability of language that's
proposed so with that and at the risk of
continuing to take up the rest of your
time and delay the inevitable
presentation by The Liquor Commission um
happy to take any
questions that was great representative
spear we had a couple of bills last year
and I suspect we're going to be having
more of them when a business does
something that
definitely seems to be illegal to
somebody I mean it's hurting the
consumers but it's online the business
is online do you have any reach into
outof
State Bad actors this is a really really
good question and the answer is it
depends so you know and this is
something I probably should have
emphasized as I was describing um the
consumer protection act one of the most
critical pieces and necessary pieces of
the consumer protection act and our
Authority is that the trade or Commerce
um happened in or affect the state of
New Hampshire
so if the business is operating in the
state of New Hampshire that's easy
they're here they're selling their
product here they're you know servicing
this state that's happening in the state
of New Hampshire if the business is out
of state um and they just have a website
and you know a New Hampshire person
happens to access it um probably not a
sufficient Nexus
probably unless they
I mean actually let me walk that back um
if you're online and you're just putting
something out for the whole world to see
and somebody is you know you know Falls
for it in a certain way we'd have to
prove that the business anticipated that
the thing that they're doing could
reasonably anticipate the thing that
they're doing would impact potentially
trade or Commerce in the state of New
Hampshire and a great example of this is
um the Attorney General's office has
brought two cases again one against meta
and one against Tik Tock um for
intentionally designing their platforms
in a way that they knew was addictive to
young people and harmful to young people
and we argued a motion to dismiss on the
medic case and one of the issues that
was raised was meta in California um it
can't be brought into New Hampshire
because you know it's it can be accessed
anywhere so there's no specific New
Hampshire Nexus we argued that because
meta enters into a contractual agreement
with each and every one of its users
regardless of where they are that each
time a New Hampshire person goes and
wants to open a meta account um and
agrees to their terms of services and
says yes I accept and then meta is
providing services to that consumer that
that was a sufficient Nexus for trade or
Commerce in the state of New Hampshire
and at least at the motion to dismiss
level the judge here in Marat County
agreed with us on that point so our case
is continuing so that's that's the sort
of calculus we have to do there's no
clear cut line but if an outof State
business is doing something that they
either know or reasonably should know is
going to impact trade or Commerce in the
state of New Hampshire we have an
argument
I'm going to be talking to you because I
got
one okay oh we do have one more question
yes yeah so this question from is from
my own better understanding is it fair
to assume that uh your Bureau acts only
when some consumer or somebody uh brings
a complaint or files a complaint or is
it that uh you have resources to uh
actively or proactively monitor if wrong
practices are going on how how how does
the bureau act another really great
question um so to understand to answer
the question is we do both um complaints
so we have a Consumer complaint process
um which I probably should have
described you so we we have a volunteer
hotline um that is five days a week
anybody can call into the AG's office if
they you know think they have a consumer
issue or another issue they can talk to
a real person and if they have a
consumer related issue they'll be
encouraged to file a complaint um and we
have a complaint review process process
where if a consumer files a complaint
that is reasonably if you assume it's
true a violation of the consumer
protection act um we'll send it to the
business on AG letterhead and say please
provide a written response within 10
days or 14 days um that process resolves
a lot of low-level complaints and
recovers a lot of money for people um
which is a a huge tool that we use to
help consumers in the state but the
other thing that that process does is it
gives me and the bureau a great
continuous source of information
on who the Bad actors are in the state
because you know if you have one
complaint alleging bad conduct you maybe
it's true maybe it's not you have 10
okay this is somebody that clearly needs
to be looked at and will alloc allocate
resources to investigate that that's one
mechanism that we use to investigate
consumer protection issues in the state
um it's not exclusive we don't require
complaints um often times like law
enforcement will come to us and say hey
you should look at this business you
know we we think there's something going
on there um sometimes it comes from the
legislature sometimes it comes from
other state agencies but you know to
answer your question it can come from
anywhere you know we do not necessitate
that people file a Consumer complaint in
order for something to be potentially
investigated by us um but it is a really
really powerful source of information
that we use to um determine our own
investigative priorities yeah that's
really great because sometimes people
might not feel you know educated enough
or sometimes not comfortable enough to
go ahead and file it to that level of
confidence so the issue gets subsided so
I'm glad to know that you have other
means to figure that out so consumers
can file uh when they file a complaint
we have a a box that's intentionally
there um that asks for their authority
to share that complaint with the
business and the reason we do that is
because um RSA
21m something or other specifically says
that consumer complaints are
confidential so consumers have to give
us permission to share it with the
business so if a consumer checks that
box and says I don't want you to tell
the business we may not be able to
engage in that information sharing
process with the business to seek a
resolution but we still review that
complaint and we use that information to
fuel our sort of sense of the pulse of
you know who the Bad actors are in the
state and who needs to be looked at
closer so they can file a complaint they
can file a complaint anonymously they
can file a complaint and not allow the
business to to see the complaint they
could also just come and ask to speak to
an investigator in order to report you
know Consumer Fraud that they think is
happening we have a number of
investigators in the office three in the
bureau um that are happy to meet with
folks who don't want to formally put a
complaint in writing um but would rather
it's more akin to making a a report to
law enforcement that then may or may not
be followed up on so there there are a
number of avenues um but if you ever
have constituents that are concerned
about filing a complaint I strongly
encourage you to encourage them to do so
and note that there are a number of ways
that they could either do it anonymously
or prevent us from sharing it if they
have any concern about retaliation or
anything like that getting complaints
filed with us is really really important
and really puts us in the best position
to do our job so I hope that you share
that with your constituents if you have
the opportunity right but I'm saying
having said that one of the things that
that you probably have fairly good
success with is when they say yes you
can share it with the business you call
them up and The Business just realized
they just got a call from the Attorney
General's office uh they're more upt to
just say fine I'll give them their money
back and rather it's it's staggering
especially with big businesses so you
know you have yes you can be secr about
and have privacy but you're better off
having just having the AG just call them
and that
they'll they can get the resolve problem
resolved quickly especially with bigger
businesses where people have difficulty
getting somebody to talk to them and
really take their concern seriously
um it's amazing what a letter from the
AG's office will do in order to quickly
resolve a really basic issue that should
have been resolved months ago in a
10-minute phone call um it's frustrating
and concerning that we have to play that
role but we're happy to play it but it
works representa am thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking our questions um
you mentioned the new expectation of
privacy act um and I think in 2018 we
passed that Constitutional Amendment
right to privacy is now part of the Bill
of Rights uh do those two things uh go
together uh is you know is is that an
enforcement statute for any part of that
Constitutional Amendment and if you have
any suggestions for us to explain to our
constituents how they could use that new
uh expectation of privacy to their to
their
benefit I don't know that they're
connected other than that they both have
a similar intention which is to provide
a greater of privacy rights to the
citizens of the state um the data
privacy statute um is very very
specifically focused on focused on
businesses that collect and analyze and
sell your personal information based on
your activities so you log on to a
website you look at a certain thing for
a certain amount of time they record
that this person looked at this thing
for this much time then they keep that
information and the next time you come
you look at something else and they keep
that information and what they're doing
is slowly building a profile of you so
that they can sell you targeted
advertising hey this person's looked at
a lot of fishing stuff they must be
interested in fishing stuff we should
sell them ads we should sell ads to the
fishing companies directly to this guy I
don't know if you like fishing but you
know that's the idea um the data privacy
statute deals with that scenario it
gives consumers the right to know what
businesses are keeping on them to opt
out of businesses keeping information
for the purposes of targeted advertising
to in insist that businesses provide
them with a copy of all the data that
they've kept on them and also to delete
their personal data at their request and
provide confirmation that that has
happened so it's a very specifically
focused statute and the AG is working on
releasing um some information that's
going to better help consumers
understand a that those rights exist and
how they can exercise them I I'm hoping
that that'll be done in the next month
or so further question just a followup
um so I guess the the godess you'll put
out we'll explain some of this maybe but
how do we know what companies are
keeping our information are you going to
keep like a Clearing House of companies
or how do we know even who to
request a great question so part of the
bill requires a requires that the
business create a mechanism for
consumers to exercise each of these
rights but also to have a readily
available privacy policy that lays out a
very clear process for consumers to
exercise each one of these rights so
part of what we are going to do as we
build this unit and get it off the
ground is to start looking at for any
major business because California has
had a law like this for a long time so
has Colorado Connecticut has one so all
the like really large companies that
deal with the whole country are already
complying with laws that are similar to
this so they've already they have
privacy policies they should be readily
available and they should describe to
your con average consumer here's how you
can do A B C or D um we're going to
start you know going through businesses
to make sure Bas essentially like cold
calling um looking at privacy policies
to see and make sure that they comply
with New Hampshire specific statutes but
that's how it's all based on their
required to disclose to you in their
privacy policy here's how you can
exercise each of these consumer rights
and if they don't do that um that would
be an unfair and deceptive actor
practice and give us all those rights
and remedies we talked about earlier
then they'll get the letter well you
might get more than a
letter just one more brief question so
we have a private company collects our
property tax data uh in my town it's
Avatar uh they're not a they're not a
government agency but they work for the
government does that expectation of
privacy act apply to a to that scenario
where it's a a company providing
collecting data on behalf of the
government so a there are a number of
exemptions and it is quite an extensive
list of exemptions that reference a
number of federal privacy statutes um so
I it I don't know it would cover as a
general premise it would cover um
somebody Who's acting on behalf of
another business for the purpose of
collecting um data um it defines the two
categories as controllers and processors
you know controllers are the companies
that are deciding what to do with the
data the processors are the folks that
are collecting and basically providing
the the data to the controller in order
for them to do whatever they want to do
with it so as a as a general principle I
would say yes
but as you talk about like somebody
who's working for a government agency
I'm just be mindful that I'm not 100%
familiar with all the exemptions how
they apply yet so there are a number of
apply thank you very much thank you all
yeah so when I was first
elected Securities used to be a
standalone
entity and and then it was I think it
was Wayne King Senator King's brilliant
idea that uh we didn't need a separate
eny we'll just bring it
into the Secretary of State's office and
that's why you have the deputy
very good thank you Mr chair I think
I'll I will start uh here this afternoon
uh thank you uh for inviting uh the
bureau uh to present here uh this
afternoon also uh thanks to the uh
members of this committee um I I'm
joined uh this afternoon uh by deputy
secretary of state in Hennessy as well
as deputy secretary Eric forcier uh and
my name is Barry Glennon and I'm the
director of the New Hampshire Bureau of
Securities U and have been a director
for roughly 8 to 10 years kind of like
lose count after time um as you'll note
on the the fact sheet that I just uh
provided to you uh you'll note that uh
at the very outset we mentioned what the
charges of the Bureau of Securities and
that is number one to protect new
Hampshire investors uh second is to
enforce the Securities laws of the State
of New Hampshire uh ensure there's
proper and fair Capital formation here
in the state and really most importantly
to protect New Hampshire investors and
provide investor education and we really
do this by way a variety of ways first
is uh through licensing you know making
sure that the individuals that conduct
Securities business in New Hampshire are
doing so on on on a fair uh basis we
conduct examinations of Branch offices
of these entities that conduct business
in New Hampshire uh enforcement of uh
the New Hampshire Securities act uh
making sure that they actually you know
do in fact follow the law and then of
course as I mentioned investor education
so this afternoon what I would like to
do and I promise we will stay within our
lotted time Mr chair is that uh we'd
like to provide a brief overview of each
of these uh uh four areas is uh and the
various components I'll discuss the
licensing audit investor education
component uh Eric will discuss uh
enforcement the enforcement component as
well as uh risk Pool Management which is
also another uh function and uh
secretary uh Hennessy may have some uh
paring remarks no all right well we'll
see uh so at first start I'd like like
to point out that the numbers that you
have in front of you here uh really can
be bit um um uh interesting I think to
say the least particularly as you look
at the sheer number of broker dealer
Representatives uh the number of firms
here in New Hampshire you'll note that
uh just on the broker dealer side alone
uh we have well over
161,000 uh registered Representatives
licensed to conduct Securities business
in New Hampshire now certainly they're
not all here in New Hampshire um I'd say
maybe 2500 of that but they that
population is licensed to solicit
Securities business into the state of
New Hampshire so our our our our job uh
in terms of oversight is can be really
significant and why why New Hampshire
why such a large numbers of firms and
Reps well simply because New Hampshire
is a wealth Center there's a lot of
money in the in the state of New
Hampshire we have an older population uh
our median age I think we're the second
oldest in in the country next to Maine I
think Maine being the oldest uh and when
you have an older population you have a
higher number of of retirees all of
which have accumulated a lifetime of
assets and uh fortunately it's for New
Hampshire that's that's terrific
unfortunately in some respect uh those
who like to conduct investment scams on
on people go where the money is and New
Hampshire is can be is and can be a
Target uh and something that we as a
bureau really take uh very seriously so
just to generally describe the uh the
areas that we regulate I could really
kind of break it down into into two
basic categories first being broker
dealers and the second is investment
advisors and there often times um the
titles are conflated and there are a
number of titles out there that you I
know for a fact that you have
encountered uh financial representative
Financial professionals various titles
but it comes down to in the world of
Securities regulation broker dealers are
broker dealers or investment advisors
broker dealers are are firms that buy or
sell Securities on on your behalf uh for
a fee for a commission and their Duty
essentially is to make sure that
whatever it is that they are proposing
to you to purchase or sell uh is
suitable and that it com that it fits
within the mo your model your specific
criteria as far as risk tolerance um and
your investment objective and so long as
that they do that they're carrying out
their their Duty
responsibly uh and and I have to say
just you know parenthetically that in
terms of the the all the representatives
and firms that we represent they really
do a terrific job um and there's just
that small uh percentage uh that you
know go outside the lines that that we
have to deal with but I I'm very secure
in knowing that the Securities industry
here in New Hampshire is well regulated
uh and that we have an incredible
population of rep Representatives
serving New Hampshire citizens the other
uh segment is investment advisors and
how they differ
uh is that as the the title uh infers
they provide investment advice uh to uh
clients uh and will operate on a either
a set fee or may charge a small
percentage on the overall assets of the
client's
portfolio uh and their their duty is is
is a bit different first off the
services that they provide are a little
more expansive in that they will provide
in most cases overall financial plan
planning services not only just looking
at the Securities but looking at their
overall assets maybe real estate tax
considerations uh estate planning uh
within the confines that they're allowed
to do so so they provide a much uh
broader picture uh to the client and
make recommendations and uh and they are
considered
fiduciaries and when I say fiduciaries I
mean that they have to conduct business
and represent the client based upon what
is in the best interest of the client
and and that's really quite a a
distinguishing factor in in our opinion
because they they really have to watch
out for the client monitor their
activities their accounts and and make
decisions and recommendations for them
that is in the best interest of the
client where our enforcement sometimes
get into gets into play is when they go
outside you know those lines uh but more
often than not they do a terrific job
another function of of the bureau and it
is uh of course the licensing and then
an audit component and as our fact sheet
indicates we have a little over 900
Branch Offices here in New Hampshire and
we conducts audits of those offices on
an unannounced basis um and uh we'll
look at the operation of that firm uh to
make sure again that they're complying
with the law could be
advertising uh maintenance of their
client records uh and in a variety of
other matters invest advisors uh have
far more uh requirements in terms of uh
just by virtue of what they do uh but we
do examine each and every one of those
offices and that number is expanding by
the way because as you know a lot of
firms not only uh Private Industry and
brokerage but a lot of people have
actually now gone to remote working so
we have a number of Representatives
working from their homes so that has
expanded the number of offices uh that
we uh that we do review
those are two primary areas of of the
bureau a more significant I I consider a
much more significant part of what we do
uh is enforcement and attorney fory our
deputy secretary uh leads the the
enforcement area and like to ask Eric if
you'd like to just comment on on our
enforcement
Activity thank you Barry I've been with
the Securities Bureau since 2010 so
going on 15 years it's always been with
the Secretary of State's office as long
as I've been there
it works it belongs there thank you
representative hunt for your efforts in
believe maybe it was late 90s okay so
the enforcement mechanism of the
Securities Bureau is a very important
one I'm very passionate about it I've
been doing it for nearly 15 years and
our job in the enforcement side is to
enforce compliance with the statute RSA
421b the legislature has provided us a
lot of tools to do so we have a lot of
enforcement Authority we have the um
write to subpoena uh both documents and
testimony from people located in New
Hampshire and we have ways to get people
out of New Hampshire as well uh we have
a lot of tools to force compliance um
the only way to really do it on the
enforcement side is to file a suit
against them whether it's in civil court
or administratively we file enforcement
actions to bring compliance if a
resolution cannot be met now we always
try to bring resolution when we can it
does save time and resources but if we
can't the ultimate tool the ultimate
Hammer is an enforcement action again
whether administratively or in Superior
Court or
both so as Barry alluded to there are
licensed investment advisers and broker
dealers that we enforce the Securities
laws against but then there is a world
of Securities transactions that not
everybody appreciates that we also
regulate our job is to regulate all
Securities transactions in New Hampshire
not just ones that people are used to
hearing from their Brokers and their
investment advisors but any sale of a
security and the legislature has defined
security to be very Broad and includes
whole array of uh business transactions
that not everybody appreciates involves
the sale of security for example if you
start an LLC in New Hampshire and you
sell interest membership interest in
that LLC to another person that's the
sale of a security so a big part of our
enforcement world is routine sales
practice cases or frauds and everything
in between with our licensed agents and
then the other half of our world is
those that are unlicensed perhaps they
should be licensed perhaps they don't
need to but there's a whole other world
in New Hampshire where you're selling
securities and they're also within our
purview and we get a lot of cases like
that so you have the licensed world and
sort of the unlicensed world and
so we have about six attorneys that work
on enforcement in our office three are
strictly enforcement three have as you
can expect in a small agency multiple
roles but we have at any given day
around half a dozen attorneys that are
working on enforcement just to give you
a sense of the numbers we have um a
really good working relationship with
the insurance department here in the
state the banking department and you
heard from Brendan Gard the Consumer
Protection Agency we work very closely
with them as well in fact there's a
statute that requires us to meet on a
periodic basis and I think
representative hunt recognizes that
statute I think it's 21 years that was
created after frm oh you brought up
those words um yes after ever since I
think 2011 or 12 there was a statute
that requires us to meet periodically
and we do and uh we don't just meet
periodically because of a statute we
routinely work with them on cases
because oftentimes there are products or
fact patterns that involve possibly
Banking and securities or Insurance
insecurities and so we're often working
together required to meet periodically
but meeting even more often as as cases
present themselves we also work very
closely with the criminal authorities
again with Brandon gard's uh Consumer
Protection Bureau they have a criminal
component to it and we have we're proud
of many cases that we've brought with
Brandon's group and I say with because
we'll act as the agency that refers to
criminal matter but then we'll stay on
will be fact Witnesses I've been asked
to testify as an expert in some matters
so we don't just refer matters to the
doj we work with them and and making
sure that people who violate the
criminal statutes are also held
accountable so that's another big facet
it's not just the New Hampshire
Department of Justice we have a great
working relationship with the US
attorney's office to bring cases that
violate federal law and with them we
work with the FBI and so we have some
great counterparts in the Federal
Criminal um agencies as well and civil
agencies the Securities and Exchange
Commission uh there's some overlap in
our regulation with the federal
government and we work really closely
with the Securities and Exchange
Commission on matters that touch both of
our laws um mostly the Boston field
office where we've really worked closely
on a number of matters that I could talk
at length about um we're a part of the
North American Securities administrators
Association known as NASA not the fun
NASA that everybody knows about there's
an extra a on the end um but that is a
conglomerate of State Regulators it's
every single state in in the US is a
part of this organization as well as
Canada Mexico and some certain
territories like Puerto Rico Guam and we
all come together and it's a really
great way to bring cases that cross
borders so we um all of the professional
staff in our office play a role with
NASA whether they're serving on
committees or working on multi-state
matters we work really closely with that
National Organization to help each other
not reinvent the wheel on cases of
mutual interest or issues that others
have seen seen before so we have a real
good uh role there and relationship
there and the only other agency I wanted
to mention is known as the fin finra the
financial industry regulatory Authority
that's a self-regulatory agency that has
some overlapping jurisdiction with our
office as well so there's a number of
agencies that have to work together that
should work together to bring compliance
with the Hampshire Securities laws and
every year we have a number of cases
that we're either bringing on our own or
we're bring it in conjunction with other
states um that's the overview of
enforcement we're really proud of that
of that function of our office and you
probably read in the papers about
various cases we've taken and there are
many more in the pipeline we uh we have
a lot going on in the office um the
other part of our office is pooled Risk
Management Programs nothing to do with
Securities necessarily but it does uh it
is housed in our office and it's a very
important function pulled Risk
Management Programs RSA
5B is the statutory mechanism by which
police itical subdivisions can pull
their money together to purchase
insurance and that statute's been around
since the 80s and we were given
enforcement authorities beginning in I
want to say around 2009 and there are
four pooled risk management programs in
New Hampshire and they are responsible
for hundreds of millions of dollars of
political subdivision money being pulled
together for the purpose of purchasing
insurance and there's a lot of um parts
of the statute that give a great benefit
to 5B programs that allow them to have a
cheaper price there's power in numbers
when you pull your money together to buy
something generally you have a better uh
price if you pull your resources
together so that's where we come in and
we regulate and ensure that that market
is uh functioning as it should be and
that includes reviewing annual filings
these pooled RIS management programs are
required to provide us with audited
financial statements and Actuarial
reports on an annual basis and we have
another we have another broad set of
tools uh provided by the legislature to
investigate and bring compliance with
um RSA 5B and there's a number of cases
we've had in the past 15 years um that
some of you may know about in that area
and that regulatory Authority those um
that ongoing monitoring and compliance
uh continues and that's a whole other
could spend an hour talking about that
but that's another area of our of our
office that we're very proud of that is
a very important role and a lot of money
flowing through um that's a broad
overview of the two topics I'm happy to
take questions just not about cases that
are
pending perfect I'm glad you did bring
up the P risk because that that
legislation all came through through
this committee also so thank you
represent
spe as the role of cryptocurrency gets
evolves in with Securities and as it's
being defined at the federal level will
you be getting involved in in uh cases
of the various kinds of frauds that
happen with cryptocurrencies and things
like that thank you for the question
great question cryptocurrency is a topic
of of a lot of interest amongst retail
investors when
um retail investors start looking at
something very carefully that's where
our role comes in because it's very
popular right now and so we need to make
sure that in New Hampshire that we're
fostering Economic Development while
balancing investor protection our job is
investor protection we recognize
fostering Capital formation is the other
part of our job it's a balance and so we
have had cases in the past that our our
office has brought related to
cryptocurrency frauds we've brought that
by ourselves in cases of a I'm thinking
of one in particular where a complaint
came in uh related to cryptocurrency
investing and we brought that case to
its conclusion we're also I talked about
NASA earlier and you asked a question of
Mr Gerard about how do you handle with
matters that are outside of New
Hampshire and online well that's the
cryptocurrency world and so having
relationships with the federal
government and through NASA and other
states is another way to tackle that and
there are cases that are brought by
um their multi-state enforcement actions
where many states come together and
investigate and bring cases against
cryptocurrency matters we have a few
settlements like that in the past and I
won't speak about pending matters but it
is a Hot Topic and both us and the
industry and the conglomerate State
Regulators are all looking at it and I
understand there'll be more legislation
coming in if we have legislation with
respect to that you are the guys we go
and talk to we are definitely one of the
players that would be testifying about
bills that impact cryptocurrencies and
we look forward to working with this
committee through any bills that touch
upon the Securities Bureau
cryptocurrency is a very broad term um
so it depends on the the details so but
given because we have no regulatory
statute anything like this point it
would right now be under the a AG's
office consumer protection in terms if
somebody had a problem or a complaint
about that's that's where you would be
taking it at this point would you agree
with that or to some extent depending on
the nature of the complaint there is an
exemption in the consumer protection act
for those involving security so it
really depends on again cryptocurrency a
broad term used very broadly and if a
complaint came in like that I'd be
working with Brendon Gard at the
Consumer Protection Bureau to figure out
where our jurisdiction lies yeah but I
think when when we had the bank when we
had it in Banks we were we clearly
defined that it was not a security that
it's a
commodity and therefore it would not
have the privilege of being exempt from
the Securities division but maybe that's
okay oh represent pelli thank you for
taking my question so commod uh
Securities trading is a commodity online
many firms are now online so how do you
deal with Robo advisers that are really
just a algorithm is that a challenge for
your
office representative I if I could just
ask for clarification at the very end
the the type of advisor you were
referring to at at the end those uh Robo
advisor you know it's just an algorithm
and it's rebalancing your portfolio and
you know there's no person on the other
end it's a algorithm computer algorithm
well um actually there is someone at the
other end there is somebody who's I
would say pulling the strings behind the
robo advisor the one who's actually
creating the algorithms um a lot of even
larger uh Securities firms uh in in the
country have a um Robo type platform so
it it's not new uh to uh firms that have
been around for quite some time we still
hold the the the firm or the individual
behind that algorithm responsible uh if
something were to go Ary um I I think a
concern that we have is to make sure
that there's adequate disclosure to the
client that they know exactly what
they're getting into that perhaps a a
robo adviser may not be able to respond
as quickly as someone uh who's seated
right here in New Hampshire uh advising
the client um so there there are certain
risks uh with that it's untested in some
areas and then if I may just kind of
expand a little bit uh the other area is
artificial intelligence which we're
hearing more and more about and we're
seeing uh that term uh being touted in
the world of of Investments and so our
concern right now is to make sure that
if a firm is saying that or an
individual representative is saying that
well we we are supported by AI or AI is
supporting some of the financial
decisions that we're making on your
behalf we want to make sure that there
is actually U an AI technology behind
that because what we're seeing is quite
often there's not it's just a little bit
of
hyperbole uh it sounds great um it
sounds like it's Cutting Edge but we
want to make sure that there is in fact
you know that that technology uh out
there and that it's actually being
provided so and if I may Mr chair
because in the interest of time we have
just one other component and if I uh
could approach with some investor
education materials to the members of
the committee pass yes okay we love
literature thank you U and there's
absolutely no charge for this all of
these materials have been paid for by
fines and penalties imposed by The
Bureau uh and that's the the absolute
trth you've done very well with fines
and penalties yes we we U we have been
very lucrative so one an important
component of the bureau is investor
education as I mentioned before uh New
Hampshire being a wealth Center um and
uh where assets are you know assets are
here in the state and there are certain
segments of the population that are more
vulnerable than others and uh seniors
are in fact you know a a part of that
population so we do a fair amount of
Outreach to uh senior organizations uh
lifelong learning programs trying to
reach seniors and advise them inform
them of uh investment fraud scams that
are taking place in New Hampshire but
we're also expanding our message to
other segments of the population and
what I would call the Middle Market and
that would be Civic organizations you
know comprised largely of individuals
business owners uh people who also um
have assets who are approached that are
uh also in a position we making
decisions every day and perhaps even
making investment decisions without
taking into consideration all the
factors um also younger population
younger population is a concern for us
those entering the workforce so as
you'll see before you uh we developed um
under the direction of secretary
scanland and Deputy Hennessy uh
developed a New Hampshire investor guide
which is I think a terrific piece um
we've provided a copy to all
Representatives uh as well as Senators
uh describing the industry all the the
various
terminology um basic information about
investing the types of products but also
to be concerned about in terms of scams
uh questions to ask financial
professionals when you're when you're
considering uh retaining one we've also
expanded that you'll notice there are a
couple other uh pieces in in there I'll
point one out in particular that that we
developed called marriage and money uh
which you know but believe it or not
when you marry there are so many
different considerations that you have
to keep in mind uh that is uh what
happens to debt you know joint debt or
or how is that held um modifying your
your your governmental documents you
know make actually changing your name uh
considerations about insurance a number
of financial uh factors that were were
targeting uh newly married couples and
providing them this information making
it available to city and town clerks
throughout the state because that's
where you get your marriage license uh
second is your new job uh this is a
brand new piece along with working with
financial professionals your new job is
really geared for uh recent college
graduates or those soon to graduate and
all the considerations when you begin a
new job pension if there is a pension
plan today um your 401k investing in
your
401k uh purchasing your health insurance
all these other Financial considerations
that are not necessarily geared toward
financial fraud but just making
important financial decisions that's
that's part of our role as well uh so
with that um I'll will certainly answer
any further questions of of the
committee uh representative Walsh has a
question oh and these are also available
in in Spanish as
well thank you Mr chair I just wanted to
comment that um director Glennon came to
my town committee came down south
traveled down south and made a
presentation at the Hamstead Kingston oh
yes yeah I remember that our committee
and uh it it was a big hit and he did a
great job and I highly recommend uh that
you utilize this fabulous resource of uh
director Glennon and his Department
because it was and he brought these and
handed them out to everyone so it was
great and thank you love to have you
back and we extend the invitation to any
representative that wishes for the Bure
to speak to your group and Mr chair
before we leave um I I I just want to
point out uh that I've had the
opportunity to appear before this
committee for 15 20 years or so um I am
retiring at the end of this month oh but
I just wanted to say to you uh
representative hunt that I I truly um uh
I want to thank you for your support of
functional regulation here in New
Hampshire all these years recognizing
the importance of the of each of of the
state agencies whether banking Insurance
Securities but also uh the concept of
exclusive jurisdiction over their
respective areas you've been real
champion of that and it has helped us
enormously over the years so thank you
my very
welcome okay thank you very
much and last but not
Commission see I always thought the
benefit of marriage was that it's the
like that you I already have a copy yeah
that's
good and uh we I think we're batting a
thousand here we're getting we're
getting the the chairman here there
evidently when Commerce calls the
uh the big the big cheese Big Cheese
shows
you good afternoon Mr chairman good
sorry about the delay we no problem
thank
you
okay so good afternoon Mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
I'm Joseph mikica chairman of the New
Hampshire Liquor Commission and with me
is our CFO Tina deir so you have a
handout in front of you
uh which is our updated primer for
2025 so we'll start out on page two
listing that there's uh 17 control
jurisdictions in the United States and
of course Maine and Vermont are two as
well our neighboring
states uh the three tier system on page
three which includes the manufacturing
tier wholesale what what are the black
spots on the control
states do those like certain cities or
something have local control or those
just accidentals like Minnesota
idea that map's been provided to us
their counties their counties they're
controlled counties okay that's what the
chief is telling us okay he's the chief
enforcer so we always we always believe
him
okay sorry sorry to uh no that's
okay good
information who do so on page four we
got quickly into the value of the three-
tier system and uh just as part of the
three-tier system product tracking is
the biggest piece of the three-tier
system uh which prevents the sale of
Tainted and counterfeit alcohol and just
for uh uh just just for a note methanol
which is included is industrial cleaning
products is the biggest piece of Tainted
alcohol and last year in 2024 worldwide
1200 people were affected and 400 people
died from tainted
alcohol u in the past five years 11,800
people have been affected by tainted
alcohol again containing methanol and
4500 people have
died so
when you look at our control system uh
obviously the those stores are retail
outlets they're there for the buying
public but they're also a control piece
so everything that goes through those
stores is tracked counted every one of
our stores is is camera uh for a various
reasons and part of the control model is
keeping control of that controlled
substance so on page five will go to
competition back in 2011 governor
Patrick signed a bill which increased
the amount of liquor licenses that could
be held in the state of
Massachusetts uh basically that opened
the door for Total Wine to come into the
to the state of Massachusetts uh total
is our biggest competitor and they are
the biggest Revenue producer uh in the
nation's largest independent Wine and
Spirits retailer they have
277 stores in 29 States they have 11,000
employees at this point they have eight
2016 when they opened their first store
and they have also opened four stores in
Connecticut and that becomes significant
uh when we break down where our business
comes from because 25% of our business
comes from Massachusetts and 50% of our
business comes from crossb
sales so on page six we'll take a look
at the national Global factors impacting
alcohol sales and we'll notice on the
bottom line of the first paragraph is
for the first time in nearly 30 years
there's been a decline in alcohol sales
Nationwide minus 2% in
2023 so that's a 30-year run of increase
and a 2% decline in
2023 we're looking at about and that's a
nationwide figure we're looking at about
a
5.2%
Nationwide in 2024 and they figure it to
level off at a total of about
5.6% decline
so there's a few positive signs in the
alcohol business uh obviously
um sparkling wine beer and Al
alcohol-free Spirits all of which we
sell in our stores uh are seeing an
uptick we're seeing a lot of uh dry
January sober Octobers so there's kind
of a lot of pressure on the Alcohol
business uh now Nationwide and if you
look on page seven for the first time
more Americans are using marijuana on a
daily basis than alcohol and uh what
we're seeing the numbers that are out
this year 33% of the people over the age
of 21 last year were using cannabis in
some shape or form this year it's gone
up to
44% so and anti-alcohol organizations
such as a Neo
prohibitionists uh and the World Health
Organization has also now claimed that
no level of alcohol consumption is safe
so alcohol is under a little bit of
attack just as part of uh
part of our Revenue impact as
well so on page eight we'll notice that
the surrounding states Massachusetts has
355 licensed retailers for cannabis and
you can see the the numbers that they've
done Maine has 218 licensed retailers
and Vermont which is in their second
year of business has 79 retailers and
they have paused taking uh any
additional licenses in putting licenses
in play so uh The Liquor Commission
doesn't take a stand either Pro or
against but when we see the decline of
Revenue we have to understand where it
comes from we're here to inform and
support and part of the information that
you need to have is that
cannabis health
impact and Baby Boomers aging out of the
liquor Market are three of the biggest
pieces that are causing alcohol Hall
decline
Nationwide so we can move on to an
operational overview on page
and 56 are leased at the bottom you'll
see that we run under and are governed
by RSA 176 colon 3 which optimizes the
profitability of the commission we're
here to maintain proper controls and
assume responsive and effective
operation and provide service to our
customers we'd like to add the word
exemplary in there so that's what we
that's what we set out every day to do
and in redoing our stores and Outlets
over the years that's what was our
vision of being able to serve our
customers
better on page 11 you'll see see that
the the commission is made up of three
divisions the organizational structure
we have the office of the commission we
have the division of enfor enforcement
we have the division of administration
and the division of marketing and
Merchandising and the correspond
sponding full-time positions that are
involved in those and if you'll notice
that the
285 classified positions in the division
of marketing and merchand in all that's
including all of our full-tim in all of
Outlets uh let's see the division
responsibilities on page 12 uh you'll
notice that second bullet we have 6,200
lenses which is under the division of uh
enforcement uh we have the division of
administration which oversees the
finance Services doit human resources
auditing plant maintenance inventory
control and legal services one of the
things that we've uh asked for this year
which is also included in the budget
numbers that we've put in is to break
out the finance piece which was a
recommendation from one of our prior
audits to put in a Director of Finance
so that would be broken out of the
director of administration and those
financial services those 22 23 people
would be under a new Director of Finance
and as I said that number is already
included in the budget that we've asked
for uh page
13 uh NextGen project a little update on
that NextGen is what we call the update
of our front of the house and back of
the house systems at The Liquor
Commission uh we had a 40 year
old plus or minus system which was
called mapper which the liquor
commission had used for many many years
and quite frankly and openly had kicked
the can down the road as to whether they
would update it or not it was long
overdue uh there was only two
individuals working for the Liquor
Commission which were both part-timers
that were able to work on and adjust
this system so we've uh certainly uh got
our life expectancy out of that one and
we've moved on to a new system uh with
which is uh a Microsoft system D3
d365 which is a cloud-based system which
will allow the uh Liquor Commission to
sort of step into this century and do
the types of things that uh retailers
are doing today uh with much more ease
there's a there's a a cost that Tina
will go into with having that system so
we have gone from basically a zero cost
having a couple of part timers work on a
system to nearly uh $7 million so um
certainly worth it in the long run but a
big step forward for the Liquor
Commission and uh although we're not
seeing it in the revenues this year it's
certainly part of the asset that we've
created for the state in updating the
Liquor Commission so at this point I'll
hand it over to Tina and she'll take you
through uh the revenue trends and the
language thank you very
much good afternoon on page 14 you're
going to see our uh net profit history
the first uh graph that you see is from
the Inception of in 1935 to 2024 we've
provided 4.6 million to the general fund
and in 19 I mean uh in the chart further
below you'll see the 10-year history of
our trend
um in FY 24 we had uh 25.4 million less
than in FY 23 and there are two main
factors for this reduction you have
first our gross profit was down by about
7 million and this is because of the
increase in costs in uh products and for
an increase in discounting to try and
try and stay competitive um and keep our
customer base and the second we had
increases in our expenses the expenses
increased by uh 16.5 million and this
primary factor was 9.5 million in
salaries and benefits so we had 4
million for full-time position changes
we had to bring in some new positions
for the new system and then the 10% pay
raise that went into effect for fiscal
year
24 yeah and then there was 3.5 million
increase for our part-time for salaries
and benefits and for the um rate change
in pay so we now bring in our
part-timers at a higher rate of pay to
compete with other retailers and that
had a $3.5 million impact and then
benefits were a $2 million increase and
then finally we had 5.5 million for
depreciation on our new system because
that is being depreciated over a
five-year term so it's a a large hit in
one year to
start on page 15 um you're going to see
our FY 24 actual Revenue transfer to the
general fund and then our estimates for
25 26 and 27 and these are all based on
the current
trends Row one has net revenue um it's
down in fy2 but is projected to be up
slightly in 26 and
27 uh row two and four I mean 2 to four
are the transfers to the other funds per
the rsa's governing reeven Revenue
transfers prior to our transfer to the
general fund so there are two
rsas um and their language is listed at
bottom of the page the first transfer
requirement is the
17616 and that's the 5% of our prior
year gross profit that needs to be
transferred to the alcohol abuse and
prevention
fund and then you have RSA 126 colon AA
and that's the transfer to the granted
Advantage healthc Care Program and it's
it's also important to note that within
this RSA um there's a provision that HHS
can determine if there is a shortfall in
the fund they can request request
additional funds from the Liquor
Commission to offset that shortfall so
this year we've just received a letter
that they're requesting initial 1.1 to2
million is what they're anticipating
which are not in the
numbers um then you have on row five
that's the actual transfer to the
general fund after the transfers to HHS
and then beer tax and you come to the
fund so on page 16 this is just a
fiveyear history of the revenue and
expenses and as you can see that there
was a peak in Revenue uh during covid
and we've had a decline in the Years
following and then you'll also see that
our expenses were pretty flat um prior
to this this year where we had the large
expenses on slide 17 this is just our
Revenue broken down into our three main
category sources you have beer tax um
liquor and wine revenue and then our
other Revenue which includes licensing
Lottery direct shipping permits and
Revenue oops miss a page
on page
18 this is a breakdown for FY 24 which
is our sales by our customer types and
buy spirits and wines in accessory
categories so retail sales are through
our 65 retail outlets on- premise sales
are sales for restaurants lounges um
brew pubs and Social Clubs and then the
off- premise are sales from convenient
stores Grocery Stores um and then retail
wine stores so you'll see that retail
Spirits are 50% of our business retail
wine is
22% and that's a total for retail of
about 7
71.5% of our business and then you'll
see on the pie charts the breakdown by
the spirits and wine in each of those
categories on the next slide um these
are the top 15 outlets for 24 they were
200 they made up 285 8 million with
seven state-owned locations and they
h on the gra on the um map
yeah um don't think the numbers the
locations are correct but I think the
updated I noticed that a little late in
the game I wasn't able to finish
it hoping nobody
[Laughter]
noticed um so on slide
20 um the agency uh sales there are
three licensed uh agency stores that
sell spirits and wines you have uh
Greenville in the southern part of the
state and that was established in 2003
and then there are two licenses in the
North Country Pittsburg which was
established in 2005 but you'll also see
that uh for arol there's a breakout of
two locations and that's because the
arrol General Store went out of business
and LL Cody took over the new
location and with that I'll turn it back
to the chairman for marketing and
Merchandising okay thanks Tina
okay so on page 21 we'll look at the
marketing and Merchandising uh page 22
you'll see that we have 65 retail
outlets warehouse and
distribution uh warehouse space 240,000
square feet the DHL Warehouse in Bow is
a contracted Warehouse we have a 20-year
contract with DHL and we are in our 11th
year of that
contract so the overview is that they do
merchandising our they do our
negotiation negotiating and purchasing
and pricing for products and advertising
is all part of uh the
marketing
division retail outlets you can see that
we have nine state owned about 141,000
square fet and 59 least
573 th000 Square ft and now 37 of those
Outlets uh do curbside
pickup our state-owned
uh stores as of 2024 do about 21% of our
business 156 million on slide
24 on slide
25 since 2012 we've updated and
relocated uh 44 of our Outlets that
that's pretty much over and done with
there may be a few others along the way
over the years but the majority of them
have been done um recently we opened a
new store in Derry and new outlets in
Nash and
Keen at this point we're finalizing the
Redevelopment program of our properties
on 95 North the RFP has gone out um
we're waiting for the finalization of
the purchase and sales agreement and the
master develop vment agreement before we
bring that selected bidder to governor
and Council for
approval on page 20 just some quick
photos of these new outlets and the
sales that they've done the Dairy Store
the new nashaa
Swansea so marketing
goals are to bring the best products and
values to our customers obvious viously
that's more important now than ever
because of Total Wine having those 12
stores in New England and again as I've
said 50% of our business comes from
crossborder sales so we have to be very
sharp and Keen in our pricing and our
discounting because a lot of that
business comes from outside of our
borders on page 30 you'll see that our
website we have 125,000 th000 visitors a
month and our in store pickup on the
right hand side is about 3.2 million in
sales with an increase of
2.1% over 23 and 12.2 million year to
date since the implementation of the
curbside pickup so you can go on the
website order your product pay for it
and pick it up in the stores or we'll
bring it out to your car and deliver it
and one of the goals in the near future
is home delivery of
product on page 31 just some of the
advertising and marketing we've done uh
and we continue to do on a monthly basis
a few displays in the
stores and some of the things that we've
added over the years on page 32 just an
update on how we use our monthly sales
to promote it via email inore Outlet
digital advertising and social media and
social media has become a huge part of
our business as as it has with any
retailer we have uh 10,000 over 10,000
followers on Instagram we have 162,000
plus followers on Facebook and we have
about
7300 followers on X we send out seven
targeted emails a month to each email
address that we have so we find a
balance between bombarding people
with emails and making sure that they're
getting a look at the products that we
have for sale and the great prices that
we have and you can see that that's
working because of the on page 34 you
can see that 92% of our reviews Google
reviews are uh either four or five star
ratings that's important to us consumers
are active on that platform and they
tell us what they think and it seems to
be very
positive on page 35 charitable
contributions which are not charitable
from The Liquor Commission but in
concert with our broker Partners uh you
can see some of the the charitable
organizations that we've uh given to
over the years since 2015 and we have
raised nearly $4.3 million for those
organizations
and at this point I'll ask the chief to
come up and he can walk you through the
enforcement licensing and education
piece and then we'd be happy to take any
have awesome thank you
chairman uh for those of you first of
all for those of you who I know very
well um congratulations welcome back um
and those that are new uh
congratulations also and uh we do a lot
of good work in this committee and and
uh we we plan on the same good work
moving forward uh for this uh this
coming year um so moving to the uh
presentation if you uh flip over to uh
page number seven uh 27 um a lot of you
know our mission and vision statement uh
we call it the new uh 37 I'm sorry 37
thanks I heard Whispering too um good
looking out
um we referred to it as the new liquor
enforcement eight years ago a lot of you
know that I came over from uh division
of state police after 28 years and and
we uh reformed restructured uh liquor
enforcement um with that in mind came a
new Mission and a new vision um the
division of Licensing and education uh
dedicated itself to education as the
foundation of what we do on a daily
basis uh not only for our consumers but
our leny holders we believe that a
partnership a true partnership between
us and our lenes was Paramount in both
of our
successes um and and is proven year
after year um in in both of our
successes um with our vision we we look
look forward to administering these laws
in a fair and Equitable fashion um and
and are very open to uh constructive
criticism and or just new creative ideas
we believe that our success is being
just as creative as the industry is and
that being uh at the Forefront of our
minds we we believe that we need to be
open for those
conversations um about three years ago
we became CIA accredited um those of you
that know the law enforcement world uh
CIA accreditation is the gold star
accreditation throughout the world um
with that in mind uh International
Chiefs of police uh Noble
iacp um uh perf and all those law
enforcement organizations have back this
as the number one accreditation for law
enforcement agencies we are are a
full-time sworn Juris a full
jurisdiction law enforcement agency not
under the purview of anybody else other
than the Liquor Commission um and and
with that in mind um we we are now the
only state agency that is clear
accredited and one of only 20 in the
state so we we as you can tell I I spent
a lot of time on that we're really proud
of it it took us a long time to get
there um and there are some agencies in
this state state that just because of
the way they structure just won't make
it to that point um if you go to page 38
you'll notice that the three prong
approach for liquor enforcement
enforcement licensing and
education um enforcement like the
chairman said earlier we look at the
three- tier system um and we inspect and
regulate that three- tier system
accordingly um to add to that tobacco
products um tobacco products is in our
purview um we work very closely with Dr
um in our relationships there to to uh
make sure that that
industry uh sells their products in a
safe manner um licensing uh licensing
we're really proud of because with that
partnership that I spoke to about
earlier uh we're able to have open
conversations providing guidance
guidance to our lenses uh through the
application lure procedure you will hear
this constantly through the associations
that that come and testify before you um
and again our foundation uh in in
creating another solidified partnership
with our stakeholders on awareness and
education is education um and we talk
about uh alcohol control laws
administrative rules and responsible
business practices we we talk about that
constantly with our lenses and share the
trips that happen and the successes that
happen without divulging of course uh um
uh business Secrets amongst each each of
these businesses that creates the
successfulness of them so if you turn to
page 39 you'll look at the uh Staffing
levels for the division um they go back
to 2009 just to to show you uh how how
we've uh gotten to this point in 2025
uh we started with 26 total sworn
positions uh in 2011 the division uh
went through some reductions uh but as
you uh heard from the chairman earlier
and and I will reiterate um the amount
of lenes have have almost picked up uh
2000 since the time I came in eight
years ago um we now are um a total of 21
sworn uh investigators our lense e to
investigator ratio is about 413 almost
414 lenses per uh investigator and their
responsibilities on a nightly basis um
we also have um 11 part-timers our
part-time uh contingents sworn
contingent um is there to support our
stores in loss
prevention uh fraud Rings theft r Rings
um I will tell you every one of their
backgrounds come from large
municipalities throughout the state um
Manchester conquer nashwa PD um to to
mention a few uh State Police is another
one so so this this level of
professionalism is at an ultra high
level um we we really hold that near and
dear to our hearts um page 40 uh you'll
see our licenses
uh that uh a lot of you are very
familiar with because we talk about them
quite often in this committee we have 52
license types uh for uh uh liquor sales
um of course like the chairman said
earlier uh everything that we deal with
is in title 13 uh it's very neatly
placed into that title so uh uh if we
have any questions or our lenses have
any questions about any of the liquor
laws um it's easily
referenced um again just quickly
reiterating on and off premise um just
to give an example on premise because
this gets confusing on premise are
restaurants lounges brew pubs Social
Clubs um off premise would be a
convenience store or a grocery store or
retail wine Outlet moving to page
41 um number of liquor licenses and and
revenue collecting in fiscal
24 um license types our on premise
license types were
2183 off premise and and I'll qualify
that with that is always day to-day a
moving Target all these numbers are a
moving Target um off premise
2147 direct shippers those that yes Mr
chairman those uh that ship into our
state um are
1369 uh manufact instate
manufacturers uh and out ofate
manufacturers are
182 tobacco only retail is 223 and
special one day is 177 making our 600 uh
licenses um revenue and 24 taxes that uh
uh
$127 uh fees 4 million uh2
21,1
16335 uh fines
142,00
2388 in miscellaneous uh
33,000 I'm sorry
333,000
62233 where's the direct shipping how
much revenue am I bringing
in have that number in here tin I'll ask
Tina to get get that number for you and
I know that's very near and dear to your
heart Mr chairman since uh you were the
sponsor of that bill I'll just uh just
speak briefly for the to the committee
the uh there's 13 control states that
are allow shipping of wine into their
States from outside of the state of
which we are one and there's eight
states that allow the shipping of
spirits into their state again which we
are one and just to step back for a
minute where the the chief talked about
uh pilage and the word in the in the in
the business we use is shrink our shrink
is less than one half of 1% of our total
sales pretty consistent year-over-year
so the uh enforcement division does a
great job with being in our stores uh
you know being touching our
customers guiding them they see they see
the enforcement people in our stores and
they also are a huge help to all of our
uh employees in our stores to know that
those folks are there and and kind of
watching over them on a day-to-day basis
thank thank you sir um very good point
uh one of the things that's Paramount to
us and and near and dear to us also is
the fact that our customers feel safe
when they come into our stores and and
that was one of the other prongs of of
taking on the loss prevention and to
have this law enforcement group in our
stores uh very softly but handling
things uh at negative instances when
they happen if they happen uh we like to
be proactive not reative active so it's
it's worked out really well it's a good
group um so if I can move to the next
page uh which would be
42 um education efforts so public aware
I said earlier public awareness
education is our foundation um if you
don't know why you did something wrong
you'll keep doing it wrong so we would
like to partner up and and teach uh the
right things and one of them that we
teach is is our fatal choice
efforts um our our our well not anymore
our Millennial group right it's a it's a
new group out there um our our
vulnerable age group um are very smart
in this in this state and and sometimes
they need to touch the stove and we
don't want to put them in cars and give
them alcohol to find out what negatively
can happen there right I mean it's not
what we what we Proclaim but what we can
do is put them into a control
circumstance with a uh driving simulator
or a golf cart that is uh chaperoned by
an instructor with with dual
controls um with our drunk goggles and
we allow them to drive through the cone
patterns uh to see how uh impairment
does affect your operation of a motor
vehicle we do it in uh a majority of our
high schools um it sometimes we have
problems with scheduling because we're
asked to do it so often uh but it's the
opportunity to get into our high schools
and talk to our vulnerable age group is
just one of the most satisfying things
that I do as a director of the agency so
or the division so um our mobile
Outreach unit which is funded by navka
um also has a driving simulator in it um
we take it on the road with us I hate to
equate it to the bookmobile but it's
like a bookmobile um it goes out to our
J our
municipalities um to to do uh PR events
uh and talk to kids and adults about uh
the negative effects of alcohol uh I
thought it was a booking mobile because
you can book somebody you can book
somebody right don't you have you used
to you used to be it it used to be
historically it used to be the
DWI uh Command Post um we don't uh run
it that way anymore is it the same
vehicle cuz I don't remember it the same
it's the canopy on on the other well it
was closed um it is the same vehicle we
rebranded it we put new decaling on it
and we put the driving simulator inside
of it
cool uh continuing with our uh
educational efforts uh we have buyers
beware it's a campaign that actually is
on the table right now to uh spruce up a
little bit but it talks about the
dangers and consequences of providing
alcohol to miners um alcohol awareness
posters are what we do in our uh grammar
schools um again participating schools
provide we're providing the opportunity
to their students to turn around peer
pressures and uh send a message a
positive message to their friends uh
that alcohol doesn't have to be a part
of their lives in the vulnerable age
group um presentations
um sometimes you'll see me running in
here a little late um it's because I'm
usually at a high school doing a
presentation we do a lot of those on a
yearly basis um again they're really fun
to do and it's really good to get our
ear close to the ground to listen to the
trends that are going on both negative
and positive um every couple weeks uh
some of you have heard me uh I do a
radio show with Jack Heath down here at
Benny um and we talk about our education
efforts uh that that radio show allows
us to hit uh approximately 95 uh,
listeners at one glimpse so again it's
another support mechanism to get our
message out there um to to all the
people not only in the 603 but in the
tri-state
area page 44 is uh talks about our
programs um I we have an abundance of Ed
a very robust education program for
teaching our managers uh and lenses
licens servers one being our uh manager
training seminar um MTS we call it uh
it's an inperson uh course that is
actually um required by Statute um that
all managers or persons in charge take
the course it highlights the applicable
laws uh that businesses and lenes must
follow during
operation uh materials designed uh for
those in management level positions for
both on and off premise uh lenses our uh
go Grocer's education training seminar
um very similarly but actually talks
about grosser clerks and and placement
of alcohol inside of a uh an
establishment whether it's a a grosser a
big box grosser or a smaller convenience
store and again uh very similar to our
managers training assist off sale
licenses and their employees to better
understand and perform their jobs duties
relevant to the sale of age age
restricted
products
um lastly in this section uh our team's
training uh I know a lot of you um uh
listened to uh Lizzy's Bill last year
this is the training that correlates
with that that bill uh that was before
you um it is the training of employees
on premise uh providing iners and or
online uh training assisting the lenses
and their employees to better understand
New Hampshire Liquor and be liquor
beverage laws and tobacco laws and apply
the concept of responsible sales and
again service of restricted products and
and um being aware of the vulnerable age
group that might be out there that that
might try to partake in an alcoholic
beverage or purchase an alcoholic
beverage continuing on page
45 uh licenses uh lensey education
program uh we also do the same training
for our own people as you'll see in the
first one liquor and wine Outlet
training um we we take our training of
our own employee is very very personal
and and it is very positive they help us
out with with telling us what the TR uh
Trends are that are out there um and and
what they are seeing in our customer
base um and false identifications is
always part of that fraud Rings um if
they see that there's just great
communication between that group and our
loss prevention
Specialists um next liquor establishment
uh security training uh that's that's
more for your security staff and your
management they talk about uh and it
coincides with the next uh bullet F
fictitious ID uh training so we're
talking more about those on premise
establishments that are either uh
running during the night how do you deal
with a negative incidence that might
have occurred um getting us in involved
to help you out and and mitigating that
that problem that exists at your
establishment um again we take all these
trainings on the road uh we go to the
establishments uh we do run it inhouse
here and each and every one of you that
uh uh in this committee or in this
legislature uh could take the
opportunity if wanted to to go into any
one of our training segments and and see
it for yourselves I know some of you
have so uh and thank you for reminding
me of that by the smile so um switching
over or looking at uh page
46 um you will see that uh in 2024 our
training uh segments leny training and
liquor uh Store employee training uh
total persons train
11,155 our uh 2024 public awareness of
events are 59 throughout the state
estimating total attendance and Outreach
really proud of
135,00 people and that's probably fall a
little that's an estimate I I say it's
probably a little higher uh down below
you see uh some pictures of our uh theme
car that has a lot of great messaging on
it does some parades for us we do do uh
the conquer pis Christmas parade and a
couple of parades uh old home day
parades throughout the state um near and
dear to uh uh deputy chief Danielle
elston's uh heart uh we had been running
for years with investigator our male
mascot uh last year uh through a grant
uh
aligator has come into our ranks um and
they have done together have done some
great work uh just talking about our
mission and statement uh in vision
statement and and just making sure that
our V our vulnerable age group our kids
stay safe throughout the
state
get so at this point uh we'd be happy to
have 1.4 million in Direct ship Mr
chairman you're doing all
looks like we have some question some
committee here's my question it's kind
of you have an interesting uh uh
complicated thing here because you're a
big part of the budget and um it's
important to the state of New Hampshire
yet there's all this you know as you
mentioned there's these all these
research coming out again about alcohol
and we already know about tobacco so
where where do you see the agency you
know going forward in 10 years I mean
you know um it's kind of a dilemma I
mean should we have wet should we have
wet januaries to encourage drinking or
where do we go well we're in we're
representative we're in the the business
of uh providing protecting
the business itself we're not a public
health agency so uh much like our stand
on cannabis uh and we don't we don't
take a stand on where the Liquor
Commission will be in 10 years we know
that it's been a profitable agency since
1934 and we hope that it continues to
stay that way for many reasons not only
from The Profit standpoint but for the
from the standpoint of Public Safety for
the the people the citizens of the state
thank you represent
wals thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question I don't expect you to
have the answer although you might have
it but if you could get back to me I'd
appreciate it turning to page 26
specifically uh being in a town I'm
speaking for my constituents where you
removed a liquor store and we are all
still very upset about it uh I would
like to know uh what did our sales uh
compared to the sales of this facility
which is 2 miles down the road from
another state liquor store so it seems
kind of odd that you would move one that
was in a different town that served a
different group to a town that already
had another store literally less than
two because I've measured
it not that I'm I'm upset over this or
anything
um I'm sure we I'm sure we've measured
it as as well yeah respectfully uh I'm
not sure which store that you're talking
Hamstead Hamstead Route 111 okay we'll
be happy to take a look at what the
numbers were yeah and get back to this
store that you you opened it used to be
um uh what was it Sabers or or something
like that whatever it was um it's just
down the the same road it's a straight
line to the store at the exit 5 to the
new Dairy Store yeah okay no this store
that you moved in Dairy is 2 miles down
the straight line to another state
liquor store at Exit 5 which I think is
actually lenon okay all right but it's
still 2 miles away from another Sate
liquor store where his eyes wasn't my
betting my bet in just looking at it
I'll get you the actual numbers of all
those but I would say the traffic count
probably has a lot to do with what we
the reason and and the the biggest thing
that we do is obviously we want to be
with like-minded retailers so we want to
be where people are shopping and and
there there's retailers around us some
of the locations that we've closed are
because there is not a lot of retail in
specific areas where the stores used to
be uh we had a lot of stores that were
we we had 82 stores when I started at
The Liquor Commission we have this we
have the 60 plus now but the important
thing to note is that we have
357,000 more square feet in less stores
than we had originally so oh I'm sure
you you did the research and it made
sense you know but I would be interested
because it's still a topic of
conversation on the on the
two shop enough well it's still on the
two Hamstead U you know Community Pages
how upset people are that it left so
that I'm asking for my constituents I'm
I'm concerned about them you want to be
able to I I participated I all I can say
is is there a Market Basket or you know
next is right yes if there's a hanford's
that is like uh 1 half mile away and a
uh
Walgreens and so there are other retails
but there's no other liquor store other
than that and da Salem or plasto I would
say that I have to drive more than five
miles to get to our brand new liquor
store
congratulations hi uh thanks for taking
my question uh I just would like to know
a little bit more about statistics on
what are the percentage of the underage
drinking in last 3 four years whether it
has gone up or down and what we are
doing if it is going up so thank you for
your question representative and hello
hi um so underage drinking has actually
nationally trended down um which is a
great statistic but it doesn't mean that
we let our guard down with that um are
we right now and I talked about that
robust uh Foundation that we have those
on a yearly basis we are doing more and
more in our high schools um it's it just
took a little while to get the message
out um and it took us a little while to
to spruce up our training that we've had
for years um and some of it we needed to
be a little bit more creative with so um
we feel we're at that point we're still
looking for creative ideas to to move to
the next level but uh but we uh and I
offer to each one of you um uh I've had
people take me up on this if I'm in your
area and doing a talk at one of your
schools please come by um I'd love to
share the the microphone and and poda
let me know yes I definitely will I
definitely will thank
you all right representative CH
up so I'm from nashwa and uh we have
three now from Nash so yeah that's
that's the question I had that you know
uh actually there are two outlets in
nashwa I know one exit six and one exit
one that's a lot of crossb uh consumers
that you mentioned you mentioned that
there is another Outlet relocated is
that a third one in nashwa or is it
something relocated from nashar to
nashar
itself there only two right now but I
see here on page 37 27 nasva Outlet 32
relocated so did you relocate the
existing one from somewhere to somewhere
yeah it was in the same Plaza we just re
located to a we relocated to a
freestanding location in that in that
store so we have Coliseum a we have the
one at the Rockingham Mall we and no I'm
talking about nashwa in Nashville you
have one in exit one near the uh fitland
mall and one in exit six it used to be
exit 6 yeah so yeah but they moved
there's one over by the by the one but
the col was I mean the co
say so there are two so what is this
really located is that a new one or is
something existing one from nashar to
nashwa but
second there's three
polium the one in the at the mall and
the one that you're speaking of there's
three stores so three stores correct
okay I the third one
but so that store that was opened was in
the back of a mall much smaller and we
moved it out when uh a Pier One Import
went out of of business we moved that
store out to the front perer One Imports
that's that's the one yeah it was a Pier
One Imports and we moved it out to the
front right on the highway right out
front that store used to be in the back
of that Plaza it was high so the exit
one same it just mov okay no no and the
second okay all right second question
was uh you did mention in your
presentation that uh half of your
business comes from crossborder
consumers so does it mean that New
Hampshire is doing much better than uh
Massachusetts and other States
surrounding states in terms of uh liquor
sale or what's the reason that you're
getting half of their business because
they also have their own business as
well right they do and they have uh
Total Wine is there obviously who is our
our biggest competition thus the
additional discounting that we've had to
do in the past few years
so traditionally New Hampshire has been
one of those places that people come to
and Shop they have second homes they
come to ski they come to snowmobile
Recreation in the summertime so a lot of
that business comes through and that's
where a lot of that traffic comes from
no sales tax uh no sales tax they they
actually repealed their tax on alcohol a
few years back okay when Governor Duval
was in place because he recognized I
believe it was 8% at the time that the
tax was uh encroaching on their sales
and that's another thing that brought
Total Wine to Massachusetts so thank you
you're welcome I mean in the old days
that Massachusetts was just a lot of
little packies not small small stores
and then and then once they opened it up
which everyone thought it was going to
be the grocery stores that were going to
take advantage of that um Lo behold it
was Total Wines represent question thank
you Mr chair um I just have a question I
didn't I didn't see it mentioned in your
packet uh mainly from my own curiosity
you have a program for limited release
uh mainly Spirits I think and uh if you
could just explain I think it's a
lottery based system if you just explain
how that works and and uh how much
revenue maybe comes in from that and and
what's the secret to getting you know
the winning lottery get get on the
mailing list get on sign signing up for
the mailing list is the is the original
piece that gets you into the lottery we
do two lotteries a year now two for
general public and I can I can get you
the actual numbers but but it's pretty
staggering as to the amount of alcohol
that's brought through uh those uh items
come to us every year on an allocated
basis so rather than put them out in the
stores and have some consumers get them
and some consumers not as well as
lies we've we designed two a year so two
for lenses and two for private consumers
and you put your name in and I think
this year we gave away
366,000 bottles in one and 16,000
bottles in another I'll get you the
actual sales numbers and but it's been
we've had the most positive feedback
from our consumers since we started
doing this because a lot of consumers
don't have time to troll our stores or
our website which is really the way
people do it they troll the website for
those allocated products they go in and
buy them all and then quite frankly
they'd resell them and that was people
were you know people are making money in
the in the black market all over the
country on those allocated items Weller
papy van winko Buffalo Trace Etc so we
found that this is the fairest way to do
it and I'll get you those numbers
represented y question okay oh another
question yes representative spear
another representative from
Nash my question has nothing to do with
Nash one of the things that we talked
about last year was some kind of uh uh I
guess a video we decided on or you
decided on and presented us with a video
about uh don't over drink you know that
that there are problems with people
overdrinking I'm wondering if you're
going to be expanding on that program
and we have a lot of talk about not
getting alcohol near youngsters and
that's can't do too much for that sure
but what about people overdrinking who
are overage
well I mean you're supposed to know
better we does everything have to be a
bill I mean did we have a bill for
Education no that was that was um the
beer distributors had a video about why
we have the three tier
system well that's what the video was
about okay we I'm not even sure I like
the 3D system but that's me that's for
another story yes okay but I mean just
so kind of an educational thing that's a
little more than just one video that we
had I mean I thought that was a good
start but I kind of thought
maybe I mean we have so many DUIs and so
many other accidents and everything else
and it's it's not all just by young
people I mean I see that they announce
it in the paper every
week have you thinking about any of
those kind of things well it one of the
things I can get you the actual numbers
on on how many times that video has been
played and what story it's been played
in it's uh we actually we've done a
couple of legislatures have uh have
requested that and we've sent it out to
them and we're happy to do that you know
any ideas that you have uh you know
anything so you're you're referring to
the video that's now running in the
stores the 211 video that we designed
last year was an answer to that
legislated tourist okay so I stand
corrected it's not the beer distributor
one this is the one that the you can now
see in not all the stores have the big
screen TVs but
they a lot of alcohol adti it's on a
seven minute Loop so every seven minutes
in one of those stores that that's being
played so I we actually I think he has
another bill in again this year so stay
tuned yeah we have the number of
Impressions and how many times that's
been played I'll get that to you yeah
but you want to see something aimed at I
don't know I'm I'm thinking maybe we
need
something I really appreciated how much
effort was put into the young people
effort but with all the DUIs and
everything else that we have shouldn't
we be spending some effort
on older people
effort right that that's what the video
is for but obviously it's not totally we
can we can discuss this offline so thank
you very much gentlemen
okay uh appreciate your time thank you I
uh the last part of our our event is
that I invite uh this is we are the most
lobbied committee uh and um and I did
invite lobbyists to stick around I
didn't know realize it was going to be
this late so I apologize to them uh but
we'll this is an opportunity to meet
these faces you'll hear from them on any
given issue and uh then so Jody why
off um thank you um late in the
afternoon so just an introduction um my
name is jod gmis
I own a lobbying firm here in conquer um
my colleagues are Adam Schmidt and my
new colleague is Heidi croll who many of
you um have seen before the committee
before um in a previous role but now
she's working with us so we're very
excited um I have passed out a list of
our clients we do come to the committee
for a number of different reasons a lot
of business groups trade
organizations um Pharmacy issues real
estate issues cannabis issues etc etc so
we just want to be a resource try to
help you um if we can we have quite a
longevity and um I'll leave it at that
how you want to introduce
yourself I'll just say um good afternoon
everyone again my name is Heidi croll as
Jody indicated I'm working um with her
and Adam and I'm just happy to as she
said be a resource um should any issues
come up on any of these clients um our
contact information is at the top of the
sheet and we also have business CS happy
to give those out after
afterwards for anybody who needs them
and um we look forward to working with
all of you this session great thank you
thank
you okay Paula and you don't have to
come to mic you can just speak to us but
whichever whatever you feel most
[Music]
comfortable I think I don't yeah I don't
think okay I don't think this needs to
fine
e
okay
Curtis good afternoon my name is Curtis
you
ex well I don't know if it's official
yet but
anyway
thansu
Lindsay I know he looked familiar but I
didn't know his name so what is his name
what is your name
of and auto insurance and we do that
trade GRS
they are one
great thank
you uh Beth have visualize what what
line row you guys are in okay so we're
greaten our Bruce ber
Karen and laa McIntyre
what brings us before this the most are
they we have the American Council of
life
insurance Chiefs of police
[Laughter]
please off topic once every five years
or so you have a bill for the new
interal director Association and then
just
right
ret the convenience
stores unlike Jody has
uh
Grocers no
no you you know Robinson Rober
yeah Gast distor which is convenience
Source too have merge oh
okay
right yeah Jim Robertson just passed
away yeah he just passed away
so
okay yeah right yeah don't want to
guys so then the ski then of course
Bruce is Bruce also had the ski ski New
Hampshire God you all forgot all
everything his clients you know God what
me okay yep next
the next
group thank you nice to see all of you I
recognize a lot of familiar faces here
so I'm Tom praw managing director at
praw and
Thomas no thank you Mr chair and all of
you really appreciate say hello
Thomas
less we also have two other lob Jim our
president and Jonathan milans um who are
just with us in this room today uh we
have a number of clients about 40
clients we're here for most of them we
have uh liquor clients here Brokers
Association we have banking clients Bank
of America the morgage bankers Brokers
Association we have retail association
Walmart on that on that Spectrum we have
Ral American for tobacco issues U we
have
Pharma oh I didn't know when when yeah I
guess you just got Airbnb last year yeah
yeah so it would really be good if you
sent an email to all the members even
the ones who are not missing and
list all the customers I just got a
thank you from Bruce by the
way so somebody's still tuned in so but
I
think of us don't represent them we will
okay I'm BR Parson um R pelli you saw my
colleague Gina P here earlier today she
had to leave uh we represent the Grocers
now okay we also represent some that
will be here for we have a list that
we'll send you afterward that' be
goodies credit fidelity
Amazon theraputics dart College all over
Dan good afternoon Mr chair member of
this comme my name is Dan Bennett I'm
the president Association we're a trade
group representing the motor vehicle
indry
550 car truck motorcycle
Stobbs construction farm equipment uh
both franchise and independent so pretty
much um it's got an engine and tracks of
Wheels we'll take
it we also run a selfed comp insurance
for our
members public corstone issues for us as
we've heard over the years safe roads
consumer protection and then making sure
that we have anic
regulatory environment for our
businesses uh we're regulated by both
the banking and the insurance department
you heard from them this morning um we
work very closely with Amilia Mike and
and DJ p uh they're great to work with
uh they're very open they're very
receptive very accessible so a
relationship there um releasing contact
as one important point I do want to
point to on that sheet is we run an
autocap program
y
great thank
you uh I'm not sure I know who
are I thought he was with you yeah
and Jackson's mother has just been
elected Senator and will be on the
Senate Commerce
Committee small world that it
okay thank you all very much and uh I
I'm aiming to try to get uh do uh
hearings on next Tuesday but that's
based on whether I can get a committee
room otherwise it would be Wednesday um
we only have six bills in committee at
this moment so who knows what we'll have
tomorrow morning when I'll be allowed to
schedule bills so otherwise we'll try to